Okay, the board will continue and I want to announce that during the closed session, the board discussed two lawsuits, MSC and LLT et al versus the state.
And so we will then proceed with item eight, which is the CASP proposed contract.
Good morning, President Kerr, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I'm Michelle Senner, the director over the assessment division.
So happy Friday.
I don't normally get to present on Friday.
Yesterday was a fun day, right?
Baby swaddling, science instructional materials, carrot cake, full winkle.
But we're right up there because we have assessments on this Friday morning.
So I feel like I can compete with all those things.
Let's do that.
So let's get started with an action item before you.
The action before you is that CDE recommends that the board approve the proposed CASP LPAC contract amendment with Educational Testing Service or ETS.
Additionally, we recommend that the board approve the proposed UC Santa Cruz contract amendment to provide an educator reporting system.
Your approval will also authorize the CDE to make any technical edits that are needed to execute these contract amendments.
This item will also provide you with an update on recent CASP program activities.
So I'm going to begin with the program update and then circle back to the action that is before you.
So let me start with an update on our federal peer review.
On August 30th, the CDE received a notice from the U.S.
Department of Education regarding our March 2018 peer review submission.
I'm happy to report to you that external reviewers and the U.S.
Department of Education staff found that the California alternate assessments for ELA and math substantially meet the requirements of ESSA.
You're very happy about that designation because it was our first submission for the alternate assessments through the peer review process.
The CDE has responded to that letter from the U.S.
Department of Education, and we have provided them with a plan and a timeline to meet the outstanding evidence that is needed, and the timeline is well before the one-year requirement to submit that additional information.
Speaking of good news, we are still getting comments and feedback about our 2018 assessment information and accountability meeting.
Two meetings were held at the end of September.
We had 500 attendees in Sacramento, over 600 attendees in Ontario.
We also did a live stream of the Ontario event and we had 580 virtual attendees.
This year, prior to that event, we also held a two-day training for new CASP coordinators.
And we had about 270 new coordinators go through that training.
Our annual meeting, and I know there's at least one member of the board who attended, our annual meeting opened with our esteemed Deputy Superintendent Carrick Ashley making good on his 2017 declaration to perform Hamilton at this year's conference.
Is it true?
I was afraid I might get fired if I brought the video, so I don't have the video.
But it wasn't exactly the words of Hamilton, but the best educational rendition of not throwing away my shot that received standing ovations at both North and South locations.
I also did sneak it into the Smarter Balanced consortium member meeting, so I know he really appreciated that.
Anyone who follows us on Twitter at CDEassessments probably already saw the video, but all I can say is if that doesn't get you to follow us on Twitter, I don't know what will.
Now let's talk about science.
I'm happy to announce that the California Science Test, or CASP, will mark its first operational administration in spring of 2019.
I can also announce that we recently launched new practice tests for the CASP that are now available for educators, students, and their families, as well as the general public.
The practice test does closely mirror the CAST operational test.
It provides insight in the depth and breadth of the items that are on that particular assessment.
This month, the CDE will also be providing our LEAs with preliminary indicators for the CAST 2017-18 field test.
Those preliminary indicators include percent correct and an indicator category in downloadable student-level data files.
These preliminary indicators also will be provided publicly as required by the U.S.
Department of Education in the form of downloadable aggregate data files.
We will not be creating nice data displays for those preliminary indicators.
The CDE has posted for district and school use a preliminary indicator communications toolkit.
It has key messages, FAQs, and timelines within that toolkit.
As a reminder, preliminary indicators do offer a general indication of student content knowledge and provide LEAs with a broad and early indication about their implementation of the California NGSS, particularly when used in conjunction with other information available at the LEA.
We do not recommend that they look at the preliminary indicator as a standalone data point.
And the CDE will provide the board with information on the preliminary indicators as soon as that is available.
We anticipate providing you a December information memorandum.
Now let's go ahead and talk about the alternate science tests.
The CDE has worked collaboratively with ETS over the last two years of pilot testing to develop this assessment that follows the board-approved high-level test design.
Beginning in January 2019, the CDE will open the online field test for the California Alternate Assessment for Science.
This assessment is for students with the most significant cognitive disabilities whose individualized education program indicates the use of an alternate assessment.
The California Alternate Assessment for Science is a unique assessment that allows test examiners flexibility as to when to administer the embedded performance tasks to students.
It also allows some flexibility for test examiners to individualize the assessment.
As you may recall, the alternate assessment for science consists of three performance tasks and each performance task has two activities.
The three performance tasks on the field test available from January through the end of their school year are intended to be administered separately shortly after students receive instruction on the content covered in the embedded performance task.
We know the transition from testing at the end of the school year to three separate but short administrations was a challenge in 2017 and 18.
In order to address that challenge, ETS under the direction of the CDE has developed an administration planning guide.
The planning guide will assist LEAs and ultimately test examiners
The guide summarizes what will be assessed on the three performance tasks and guides test examiners in completing a performance task administration schedule consistent with their own instructional calendar.
CDE will launch a new online training performance task for the California Alternate Assessment for Science that provides students, test examiners, and IEP teams a chance to familiarize themselves with this new online version of the alternate assessment.
Now let's switch gears again to Spanish.
First, I'd like to express my gratitude to the districts that participated in the California Spanish Assessment Field Test.
The field test recently ended in October and was followed by a post-test survey to the field.
We will be using that information from the survey to make continuous improvements in the future administration of the Spanish assessment.
Like all of our other tests, we greatly value the educators that assist us in the development process.
Just recently, we had educators review the performance of the CSA field test items in preparation for the operational test.
A special thank you to those educators who are making it possible to go live with an operational Spanish assessment on April 1st, 2019.
Now that I've covered summative assessments, I have an exciting announcement related to the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessments.
I'm happy to announce that we reached an important milestone with administrations of the Smarter Balanced Interim Assessment.
In October, we hit that milestone of over 1 million interim assessments being administered.
At the same time last year, we had just over 500,000 interim assessments.
And as of this morning, we have approximately 1.5 million interim assessments that were given in California.
Based on feedback that we have received from those using our interim assessments, we believe that this is in large part due to the usefulness of the educator reporting system that was launched by the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium with extensive input from California.
Now that I've given you the brief update, I want to switch back and talk about the action that's before you today.
First, I'd like to begin by acknowledging the collaborative efforts of board staff, the Department of Finance, as well as many staff at the California Department of Education who assisted with the negotiation process.
If you have technical questions following the presentation, I may invite representatives from ETS or from the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium to come up and address those questions.
Representatives from ETS are here today, including John Oswald, Vice President of Client Relations and Outreach.
From Smarter Balanced, we have Tony Alpert, Executive Director of the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium at UC Santa Cruz.
It may be helpful to begin with a brief summary of the actions leading up to this item.
In 2016, a section was added to the Education Code that specified all California computer-based assessments utilize the same technology infrastructure.
Moving in this direction would minimize the impact on teachers, administrators, and state resources.
As you know, the LPAC is currently a paper-pencil test.
However, the legislature recently approved funding for the development of a computer-based LPAC as well as a computer-based alternate LPAC.
In order to transition to a computer-based test, as well as use the same technology infrastructure as the other state assessments, the CDE is bringing forward two proposed contract amendments, one to the ETS contract and another to the University of California Santa Cruz Interagency Agreement.
In July of 2018, the board approved the CDE to negotiate with UTS to incorporate the LPAC program into the CASP contract.
You provided us with five goals.
The first, transition the initial and summative LPAC to a computer-based assessment.
The second, continue to conduct administrations of the paper-based LPAC assessment until the transition is complete.
Three, develop an alternate assessment for the LPAC.
Four, continue the administration of all components of the CASP system through the 2021-22 school year.
And five, create efficiencies by combining two assessment systems into one administration contract.
I'd like to share just a few details about how each of those goals were met in the attachments, which I'm sure you all read the over 400 page contract that was attached, but maybe the executive summary, which is in there as attachment one of the board item.
The first goal sets the requirement for the transition of the initial and summative LPAC to a computer-based assessment.
The transition to a computer-based assessment for LPAC will make California consistent with 39 states and territories that already have their English language proficiency test on computer.
The new scope of work will ensure that this transition happens in 2019-20 for the summative LPAC and in 20-21 for the initial LPAC.
The transition will take advantage of the existing technology and provide accessibility resources to students more readily.
The transition period will allow for the establishment of a design team of national experts to consult on the transition.
The timeline will include cognitive labs, comparability studies, and usability testing to help ensure continuous reporting of test results during the transition to online testing.
The second goal assures the ongoing administration of the LPAC paper-pencil test until the computer-based assessment is complete.
We will not allow any gaps in the assessment of our English learners.
The goal ensures that English learners receive the services they need throughout the development of the computer-based LPAC.
The third goal of the proposed contract amendment stipulates the activities and timeline for the development of an alternate assessment for the LPAC that will also be computer-based.
We are committed to providing all students access to this test.
This goal addresses the development of an alternate LPAC for students with the most significant cognitive disabilities.
The timeline proposes a dedicated design team of national experts for this test development and requires a fully operational test in 2021-22.
The fourth goal of the contract amendment will assure the continuous maintenance of the current assessments and continued development of the alternate assessments for English Language Arts, Mathematics and Science, as well as the CAST and CSA.
It will also support the board and the department in activities related to the development of a growth model if needed.
The final goal of the proposed contract amendment describes the activities required to fully transition the two separate systems for the CASP and LPAC into one contract.
This contractual merge will create efficiencies and allow the streamlining of the process to create a more efficient and unified experience for students, families, and educators.
Activities defined to accomplish this goal include a single sign-on for users to move seamlessly through different assessment applications, such as the Test Operations Management System, the California Educator Reporting System, and the Smarter Balanced Digital Library.
This goal will provide for the support of electronic translated student score reports in English and six additional languages for the CASP and ELPAC by 2019-20.
Note that currently the ELPAC student score reports are only provided in English.
Additionally, the CDE requests board approval of the contract amendment with the University of Santa Cruz and authorizes CDE to make any technical edits as necessary.
Currently, the CDE has an executed interagency agreement with UC Santa Cruz for services associated with the Smarter Balanced Assessment Consortium.
Incorporated within the membership agreement is the development, deployment, maintenance, and hosting of an educator reporting system for Smarter Balanced assessments.
This system allows educators to view detailed student results from the Smarter Balanced interim assessments at the group and individual student level to help educators identify what students know and can do and where they might need additional support to master content.
The contract amendment leverages, expands, and customizes the educator reporting system for the following California assessments.
The California alternate assessments, the California science test, the summative LPAC, the alternate LPAC, and the California Spanish assessment.
The educator reporting system has been very well received by California educators, and we are excited to move our other California assessments onto that platform.
The proposed plan calls for the reporting system to launch first for the LPAC.
Once the application is customized, we will start by loading historical LPAC scores and eventually transition to nightly LPAC feeds to this reporting system.
Following LPAC, we will transition CASP assessments using a similar approach of a batch upload of historical results followed by nightly feeds of current assessment scores.
So that's a brief summary of the very long and detailed contracts that are before you today.
Okay, thank you for that brief summary.
I thought it was brief.
It's 422.
Can you speak more about the gross model?
You mentioned that.
A few more details on what's in that.
So the contract before you does include similar support as we had in the past from our administration contractor to run data files.
And if a model was selected by this board of a growth model to include that within data files that we would receive.
So it's similar support that what we had before, but that support expired, if you will.
So now it extends that.
Okay, I think the board at some point needs to revisit what our timeline is for the growth model and whether we want to get this in place for the 2019 release of the dashboard and so on.
Okay, other board member questions?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Thank you for the presentation, Michelle.
I don't know if there are technical questions, but I have two questions that are of interest to me.
With the California Spanish assessment, currently the schools that do implement a Spanish assessment, it's the Apprenda.
And so the Apprenda is not aligned to Common Core.
I know my son came home with Apprenda scores and I'm like, well, it's not aligned to Common Core, but it is telling me something.
Once we have the California Spanish assessment, will there be guidance to the field to face out the Apprenda?
So districts always have the choice to administer any locally assessment that they choose to do so.
So I do not see us recommending that they phase out any assessment that they chose.
We will be working on making sure that they understand the benefits of the Spanish assessment that we have and how it was developed to be aligned with the Common Core en Español.
Okay.
That was the one question.
And I know that not in this conversation, but we had agreed that we would come back and revisit using this assessment for accountability purposes when we have the asset discussion.
So I just wanted to put that on our radar.
For the CAST,
What was the feedback from the pilot, implementing the pilot assessment for the CAS, for the California Science Test?
Because I've heard a lot about the length of it and instructors and students not knowing that, hey, we're almost done, but, oh, there's 40 more questions because some sections were 70 questions.
So I'm wondering when we see the results, how much of it will be fatigue?
And also, I'm wondering when we will see the results because something that was a little troubling to some, my husband, who's a fifth grade teacher, is that it's based on the assumption that teachers will be teaching the concepts before you, but you will be taught, you will be tested in fifth grade.
So you're assuming that it's going to be taught in kinder, first, second, which is a little unique.
So I'm wondering what the feedback has been from the field in terms of that portion and also just the length of it.
Sure.
Well, you've really hit on two of the things that we've heard.
The first was during the administration, we had quite a few calls coming in concerned that the test was taking longer than the time that we had anticipated.
We did look at real data on the length of time a student was actually taking a test to see if that was, in case, true.
And it really wasn't.
We were happy to see that the test, on average, was taking the two hours.
Of course, there are students who take more, students who take less.
But on average, it was taking the two hours.
In fact, in high school, it was taking less than the two hours.
You know, honestly, we are still implementing the science standards in the classroom.
So may it take longer in high school when students have been more familiar with that content?
That is possible.
Luckily, we do have a computer-based system that really allows us to look at empirical data to look at how long is it taking students.
And so we'll continue to do that.
The other piece of feedback that you heard is something that we've been working with our contractor to correct, and that was because of the unique design of the cast, and it is several modules or bundles in the online system, the counting of the items was a little misleading to some test takers.
They thought they were getting close to the end, and gosh darn it, that end number just increased by 10.
What happened?
We have been working with our contractor to fix that for the next administration and then probably improve upon it yet again when we get to the second operational year.
So that is something we heard that we're working on.
Bruce Holliday.
So you have empirical data regarding how long students were taking for the test and that sort of thing.
But yesterday we had a presentation on the implementation of the science standards and we know how many districts are way behind in terms of implementing the science standards.
So when you do this sort of analysis of how long it took students to take the test and how well they did on that sort of thing, will you factor in the fact that there are areas where the standards have been
Where districts have been working hard to implement the standards and other areas where they haven't and I think you need to think about that a little bit as you as you do this if you're going to have a better perspective on how the how that pilot went does that make sense to you it makes
perfect sense.
I wish I had a data file that said this particular district is implementing NGSS in these particular grades.
Even our early implementers aren't necessarily implementing it across all grades.
And so we struggled with that.
But we do have an independent evaluator for CASP, as you might recall.
That is HMRO.
Humrow, for the next science administration, has asked that we add some survey questions to the test, and so they have provided them to us.
I wish I had them memorized by heart.
I believe there are three questions, if I remember the number correctly, and they get a little bit at what you're asking, which is, does
What you're seeing on this test does it look like what you're getting in the classroom?
And so we will have that additional Information on the next go-around for our science test and I think that will really help us when we start looking at the data Board member Williams
In response to member Ortiz-Licons, one of your comments, it was intentional, intentionally designed, the California science test that fifth grade would cover the two previous years.
And obviously the purpose of that is to get science into the elementary schools.
So that's a good thing as far as I'm concerned, and it's not a surprise that one of the outcomes I hope happens is that your husband and other fifth grade teachers tell their principals that they need to make sure that they're providing professional learning on NGSS for their second, third, fourth grade.
Students and so, you know, that's still part of the job to do going ahead.
There's not any High stakes related to this at this point in time These tests are going to be and or ever and these tests are really going to be hopefully Policy levers for motivating principals and superintendents to to get science into the classroom Okay Board member Rucker
Good morning, Michelle.
Thank you for this very detailed presentation.
I do read all of this stuff and I have to admit I got lost as I was going through certain sections of the contract that you actually made clear with your presentation.
So I appreciate that.
My question concerns another element that's not necessarily in the contract, but is equally important.
We had an information item about the update that was done on the accommodations and modifications for the SBAC test.
I tried to find the accommodations and modifications information on the cast and I don't know where to find that.
Can you give me some information about for these tests that were done with this initial administration?
Do you have any information about accommodations and modifications that were offered and what were actually used?
Offered and used, that is the number one question when we talk about accessibility supports for our tests right now.
We are getting ready to post data.
Is it just for Smarter?
Does it include science?
So for this year's data that we're getting ready to post, it will only have Smarter Balanced.
But it will include information on the accessibility supports that were assigned in the system.
We have the ability to do that, and we'll eventually be including science in that list, in that data file that we produce.
And it's on our website, and I'm happy to ensure that that link is prominent.
What we want to do in the future, and we're starting slowly on this, is also look at what did students use.
And so for the first time, we have the ability to look at some of the accommodations and some of the designated supports in the online system and look at whether or not a student used it.
As you can imagine, the data file is by individual student by individual item.
And so this is a massive amount of data.
We haven't actually received the data, but our contractor has, and they're just starting to look at how you might analyze that and how we might make decisions on what does it mean to use something if a student selects it a glossary once?
Was that using a glossary on one item?
If we look at the distribution, is there some kind of threshold?
We say, oh, well, maybe if they used it on 10 items, that student used that support.
So we're just starting down that road of how you would analyze usage versus assignment.
And then at the same time, as we're looking at that data, we're thinking about what are the questions and the guiding questions that we would ask our schools and districts to ask themselves if they see discrepancies between assignment and usage.
It could be for many different reasons.
It could have been an appropriate assignment, but yet the student maybe didn't have enough training on where to find that support and how to access it.
Or maybe it was an over assignment and the student didn't really need that support.
So there's all kinds of reasons why there might be discrepancies.
So we're also looking at some guiding questions that, so when the data is posted, they could reflect on discrepancies that might exist and start to rectify.
So, we're just starting down the road.
We know that that is an area that we need to really analyze more closely.
And luckily, in the world of online testing, we will have access to that kind of information.
And I appreciate your answer and the thoughts that you put into some of the guiding questions because that is my concern.
I'm still seeing memos from a lot of LEAs that are actively discouraging teachers from assigning accessibility supports.
whether it's for a student who has an IEP or has some type of special need or for general education students.
Even though Smarter Balanced has done a great job of expanding and writing very clear guidance in their accessibility supports manual, districts still don't understand that it's available for all students and that there is no penalty for allowing the use of some of those accessibility supports.
So, but not being able to see what was written for accessibility supports on the cast
itself, I want, I'm curious about, you know, how well done that information was developed for that assessment.
And so at some point in time, I'm sure as we start down this road, there's going to be a difference in what's been used on the English language arts and math assessment and what's been used or provided on the CAST assessment.
So I think this is something worth monitoring and following as well.
Sure.
We have, we lovingly refer to them as bento boxes.
They're the box that has all the little squares and tingles on it.
So we have that for all of our assessments that indicate what is available.
What we have on our science test is very similar to what is available on the math.
I mean... Okay.
And see, I don't know because I couldn't find it.
I couldn't figure out where to look for that.
So I'll talk to you after the board meeting so I can take a look at it.
Thank you.
Okay, any more questions on this?
We have some public comment.
Public comment.
With the following speakers, please line up at the podium.
Doug McRae, Angela DeRamos, and Sheila Whitley.
Good morning.
I'm Doug McGray, Tired Testing Specialist from Monterey.
Brief observations on this item were found in your electronic folder last week.
I'd emphasize two points.
First, using the merger of the CASP and LPAC vendor contracts to also extend the contracts for two additional years from 2020 to 2022 is not justified.
is likely to cost California taxpayers tens of millions of dollars due to failure to conduct competitive bids in a timely manner.
Second, the 2018 budget for the LPAC paper-pencil tasks was $13 million, but it doubled to $27 million for executing the same work in 2019.
I'd note an additional one-time $27 million was budgeted for new LPAC tests and transitions for existing LPAC tests to computer-administered.
But why did the budget for existing paper and pencil tests double from 2018 to 2019 for the same workload and deliverables?
Thank you.
Good morning, Sheila Whitley for CTA.
Since the electronic system used by LEAs and teachers to retrieve data files is in a user-friendly format to access the Smarter Balanced assessment results, CTA requests that the CDE to get ETS to include, if it's not already planned,
As part of its recommendation, a guidance feature for teachers and parents that ensures clarity and the understanding of work-related administration of the LPAC, alternative LPAC, and the continued development and administration of the CASP assessments.
Okay, that concludes the public comment.
Is there a motion?
Member Burr.
I move CDE's recommendation.
Second.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
All right, we're on to action item nine.
Yeah, nine.
LPAC approved, provost original.
Good morning, Carrick Ashley, deputy superintendent, performance planning and technology branch.
Michelle will be up here in a minute to present the LPAC item.
I didn't want to make these comments prior to your vote.
I don't have many opportunities like this to talk about our assessment system, but I want to take just a minute since it's, I'm not going to sing it.
But since this, Superintendent Torrelick, since your last meeting with us, I wanted to take this opportunity to just revisit, and it'll just take me a minute, where we've been in the last four years since Member Rucker and I went to Dallas to see the achievement scores being talked about.
In those short four years, we have eight new assessments in California.
We've got Smarter Balance, English Language Arts, and Mathematics, computer-based.
We have a new alternate assessment for those students in English Language Arts and Math.
We have a new science assessment, computer-based.
We have an alternate science assessment, computer-based.
We have a new, as you heard this morning, California Spanish assessment, optional.
Other states don't have that going live this year.
We've got the new LPAC that you'll hear in a minute that Michelle will speak about, both regular.
We have an initial as well as a summative test or an annual test for those students.
We've got 3.2 million students that get tested every year.
without fail in a computer base.
As you heard Michelle say this morning, a million students in October up to 1.5 million taking their interim assessments.
We have an online reporting system for teachers that's been developed.
We now have the next step of electronic reporting for parents in multiple languages that will be coming.
I believe that in California, as our students deserve, we have the finest assessment system in the country for K-12.
And you can take, as a board, you've been involved in these decisions, you can take some credit for that.
Superintendent Torlakson, you should take some credit for what's happened in the last four years.
But I mostly want to thank Michelle Center and the leadership that she has given as our state's assessment director.
So with that, Michelle can come and present item nine.
Wow, that was so nice.
I thought he was going to wrap.
He could have.
Okay, so now on to item nine.
Again, this is another action item before you and
I will provide you some detail.
I know there were several attachments and some of them were very technical in nature.
And so let's see if we can do a good job of summarizing those attachments for you.
So the department asked the board to approve the state superintendent's recommended threshold scores that are included in attachment one beginning with the 2018-19 summative LPAC.
Approval of the recommended summative LPAC threshold scores includes the overall scale score, the oral language composite score, and the written language composite score for each grade or grade span.
Before I begin, I just want to clarify that these recommended changes for the 2018-19 scores will not impact the current English Learner Progress Indicator timeline that was approved by this board in September of 2018.
In November of 2017, this board approved the 2017-18 summative LPAC threshold scores, which were reported as a three-digit score and later converted to the current four-digit scale that you see represented in the item before you.
From February through May of 2018, the first operational summative LPAC was administered to all English learners in California.
today we are bringing to you recommended 2018-19 summative LPAC threshold scores for approval.
These threshold scores were developed using the board approved 2017-18 threshold scores and data from the first operational summative LPAC which was used to conduct two studies.
First, a threshold score validation study that used the contrasting groups methodology.
This process asked teachers to judge how their own English learners would perform on the summative LPAC and compared that judgment to the students actual LPAC results.
The purpose of this work was to evaluate the degree to which the threshold scores and performance levels of the summative LPAC consistently distinguish between levels of students' English proficiency based on the teacher ratings.
The second study was the Supplemental Empirical Analyses.
The analyses looked at how students who scored at the level four on ELPAC in 2017-18 performed on the Smarter Balanced English Language Arts Assessment.
Their performance was compared to the performance of English-only students on the same ELA assessment.
So in just a couple of minutes, I'll ask Dr. Patty Barron and Robert Liquanti to come up and present the results of their studies in more detail.
So looking beyond today, once these proposed threshold scores are approved, the English Learner Support Division will use the 2018-19 threshold scores to make a recommendation to this board on the LPAC English Language Proficiency Criterion to be used for reclassification.
I just want to reiterate that the English Language Proficiency Criterion is not in action before this board today.
Additionally, the new 2018-19 threshold scores will be implemented in the summative LPAC administration from February through May of 2019.
I would like to emphasize that California has gone above and beyond and we do our due diligence by conducting these two studies and consulting with national experts so that we can be confident in proposing these 2018-19 threshold scores.
Now I'd like to invite up Dr. Patty Barron, Strategic Advisor and Technical Liaison from Educational Testing Service, the contractor on the LPAC who oversaw the Threshold Score Validation Study, who will be followed by Robert Lincuante, Project Director and Senior Researcher for the California Comprehensive Center at WestEd, who oversaw the Supplemental Empirical Analyses.
They're going to come up and present the results of their two studies.
Good morning, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, and members of the board.
I am Dr. Patty Barron, Technical Liaison and Standard Setting Director at ETS.
I'm happy to be here again to present to this board, and I thank you, Michelle, for the opportunity.
As Michelle mentioned, there were two analyses conducted to provide additional validity evidence in consideration of the summative LPAC threshold scores.
I will be presenting the process and results for one of those studies.
That study is called the Threshold Score Validation Study.
The Threshold Score Validation Study compares student performance levels based on the standard setting workshops to results from the contrasting groups study.
The purpose of the study is to provide additional validity evidence of the summative LPAC threshold scores.
The method used in the validation study is called contrasting groups.
In this method, California educators made judgments about the performance level of their students in their classrooms relative to the California 2012 ELD standards and the summative LPAC performance level descriptors.
In the contrasting group study, a representative sample of students and their teachers participated.
Working with the CDE and their technical advisory group, we developed recruiting strategies that allowed us to include a large sample representative of schools in California.
During recruiting, we monitored the representativeness of that sample.
As the numbers of teachers, students, schools, and LEAs on this slide indicate, we had large numbers across the state.
We compared the final sample to the 2017-18 operational LPAC test-taking population.
The results showed that the study sample includes a reasonable distribution of school sizes,
Student characteristics of the participating schools were comparable to the population of schools in California.
And overall, the student sample characteristics were representative of the 2017-18 operational LPAC test taker population for those targeted characteristics, specifically gender, economic status, English language acquisition status, and home language.
So what was the contrasting groups process?
Teachers received an overview of the LPAC and the score reporting hierarchy and instructions on how the overall score was calculated and how to complete the rating form.
Teachers were provided the performance level descriptors, and they used those descriptors to consider their students' performance in their classrooms.
They were asked to complete one form per student and to provide the expected overall score performance level for each student.
And they rated their students then as performance level 1, 2, 3, or 4.
So statistical analyses were conducted.
Teachers' ratings of students were compared to the students' LPAC scores and levels from 2018-19 operational LPAC test takers.
The number of students classified at the same level, exact agreement, and adjacent agreement was evaluated.
In the contrasting group study, when we combined the ratings of exact and adjacent agreement, the ratings for kindergarten and grades one and two ranged between 85 and 90%.
And for grades three and up, the agreement rate was 90% and above.
The percentages for exact agreement were lower, and that indicates there were some differences in the ratings.
The most notable finding in the study was that for almost all grades at almost every level, the differences were in one direction.
That is, the result overall in the contrasting group study was that the teacher ratings of their students suggested that higher threshold scores should be considered.
I'm happy to answer questions if that's appropriate at this time, or we'll have Robert Lincuanti come up and do his part first.
If you could remind me, the students took the summative in the spring, is that correct?
That's correct.
Yes.
And then end of the school year.
So when did the teachers do the ratings?
That's my question.
After the.
Actually, that's a very.
Thank you for asking that board member Valdez.
So the teachers had to do their ratings before the teachers administered the speaking test one on one to the students because we didn't want them to have that information.
So it was at the end of the year, but it was before we made sure that each teacher hadn't yet administered the test before they did the ratings.
Thank you.
Good clarification.
Maybe I'm mishearing it, but you put on your slides here that the adjacent percent of exact or adjacent agreement was 85 to 90 percent for
Kindergarten grades 1 & 2 and then 90% 3 through 12, which sounds great.
Sounds good.
But you said for exact Agreement the percentages were much lower.
Do you know what those?
I didn't say much lower, but they are lower when you so
You know adjacent agreement if I have a student rated at level two adjacent agreement would be in the other study it would have been level one or level three.
So exact agreements are lower and I actually have the full report which I'm pretty sure has been posted.
I can give you some examples from this.
Hold on a second.
OK, so the exact agreement across the grades, I would say, ranges from high 30% to 47%, so lower.
So there's enough difference there that you want to consider.
It is.
Right?
Yeah, that's the point.
Thank you.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the board.
I'm Robert Lincuanti, project director and senior researcher at the California Comprehensive Center at WestEd, representing a team from that group that did this study, this supplemental empirical analysis at the request of the CDE.
So I'm going to briefly describe
what we did, why we did it, and what we found.
So let me just shift forward here.
So first, the purpose.
Why do this?
The purpose was to examine how ELs perform on the Smarter Balanced TLA test in relation to how they perform on LPAC.
And so you may ask, well, why are we talking about Smarter Balanced when we're supposed to be talking about LPAC?
Well, it's important to look at the available data on how kids do on both tests when you're considering the validity of the threshold scores that you're looking at.
So we want to know how kids do at each level of the LPAC on the academic test that they're going to be judged by.
We want to see the relationship between these two.
And just to be clear, this method was developed, these methods, this series of
was developed from a technical guide that the U.S.
Department of Education commissioned and published back in 2012.
And it involved a bunch of EL, a group of EL researchers, assessment experts, and technical assistance providers, including myself.
And these methods are now used by the 38 states in the WIDA consortium.
several states in the ELPA 21 consortium, and we also do consultations with states through CCSSO, the Council of Chief State School Officers, as well as the U.S.
Department of Education's ELP community of practice, which has 30 states.
So these practices or these analyses are now widely used when looking at proficiency levels, threshold level scores,
and when in determining or thinking about an English Proficient Performance Standard on the test.
So first of all, it's important to know the likelihood that ELs at LPAC level four, how they perform, whether they perform, to what degree at grade level on Smarter Balanced DLA.
In other words, these analysis help us to understand what's the likelihood that ELs that might be considered English Proficient, and we know that's going to be somewhere in LPAC level four, because that's the highest level,
how they also perform and whether they perform at or near grade level on the Smarter Balanced ELA assessment.
So we look for if there's an equal likelihood that students at that given level on the LPAC will perform proficient or standard met level three on LPAC ELA, I'm sorry on Smarter Balanced ELA.
or whether they perform similarly to our monolingual English speakers, sometimes called English only or EO kids.
So that's context.
So again, these methods are used widely.
They're used for validating threshold scores, so they're part of a larger body of evidence that comes together that policymakers and test developers use to really think hard about how the test is functioning and what it means, what the implications are.
I want to emphasize, though, that these analyses are not a simple algorithmic process.
It's not plug in the numbers, get the answer, you're done.
It's really, there's several other factors to consider, so this is only one input among several that state departments and policymakers like yourselves use when they're considering validation studies.
your own decision making.
And I know we're going to come back to the board, as Michelle said, in January with the department will with recommendations for the English Proficient Performance Standard to be used as one of the criteria for reclassification.
And we'll be talking about that in more detail then.
So the three methods I'm going to talk about and try to spare you the painful details of the technical analyses, which is in attachment three of the report, are descriptive box plots,
So these just graphically display how ELs at different LPAC performance levels perform on Smarter Balanced ELA.
And we've also included the performance of monolingual English speakers, the EO students.
And we also threw in the performance of reclassified fluent English proficient students, RFEP students, and the initially fluent English proficient students, IFEPs, all for comparison basis.
We also did logistic regression, which estimates the likelihood that ELs at any given LPAC scale score will score at level three on the SBAC ELA.
And then finally, we used a decision consistency method.
which seeks to identify the LPAC overall scale score range that maximizes the likelihood of agreement.
So in other words, if they're considered proficient on LPAC, they'll be considered, they'll be seen as level three on Smarter Balanced, or if they're not proficient on LPAC, they won't be level three on Smarter Balanced, and minimize the percentage of non-agreement of those things, where you'd be proficient on LPAC, but not on Smarter Balanced and vice versa.
So these all three methods are typically complementary.
They typically converge.
around sort of indications of where the English proficient performance standard is and where it might be set or whether it's too low or too high.
So let me just move next to the data set that we used.
So the department securely transferred to us the Smarter Balanced assessment data for all students in grades three through eight and 11.
You can see the numbers here.
We certainly had a robust data set in terms of EL's native English or monolingual English speaking IFEP and RFEP kids.
They also transferred the LPAC assessment data from the first summative test for all the ELs in grades three through eight and 11 because those were the grades that match up with the Smarter Balanced tests.
So just to be clear, all the analyses I'm talking about pertain only to ELs in grades three through eight and 11.
That's the comparable group that you can look at.
And to be clear, we also got from, regarding Smarter Balanced, we looked at performance levels as well as scale scores.
And with the LPAC, we also looked at scale scores and performance levels for the overall and the composite domains, and we had, of course, performance levels for the individual domains as well.
So what did we find?
There's a lot, so I'm just gonna distill this, just sort of here's the take home news.
First, let's think about how many kids actually attained level four on the LPAC.
And if you look across all the grades three through eight and 11, you found that a total of 24% of those students, those ELs across grades three through eight and 11 attained level four on the LPAC.
Keep in mind that the CELT, the last time the CELT was given in 2016-17, what was considered the English Proficient Performance Standard then, we had 40% of the kids do that.
So this is a significant raising of the bar in terms of how rigorous the demands are of this test to score at Level 4.
But that range, so it was a total of 24% in grades 3 through 8 and 11, but it varied by grade.
So it ranged from a low of 11% at grade 3 to a high of 37% at grade 8.
So just keep that in mind that it did vary by grade.
So in other words, it seemed harder at grade 3 than at grade 8 to score at that level.
Okay, so let's think then about what were the results for kids who were at level 4.
So what we found was that the methods really converged.
They all pointed out the same story, and this is it.
For grades 4 through 8 and 11, the students that are at level 4 on LPAC did not show an equal likelihood of attaining level 3 on a Smarter Balanced DLA test, nor did they approximate the performance of native English speakers, of the of the monolingual English speakers.
The only grade where that was different was grade 3.
And in grade 3, those at LPAC level 4 actually exceeded an equal likelihood of scoring proficient on Smarter Balanced and outperformed EOs, outperformed the native speakers.
But again, keep in mind, of the seven grades we analyzed, grade 3 had the fewest number of kids at LPAC level 4.
So just think about that.
The bar seemed to be set higher.
And more of those kids that were in LPAC 4 and grade 3 performed well on Smarter Balanced.
So all of these data, when we looked at those patterns, I'll just mention because it is in the report, when we saw these basic patterns on level 4, we did some additional analyses.
We looked at if we could isolate or find subgroups of ELs in LPAC 4 that would perform higher on Smarter Balanced.
Just if you think back to the performance standard on CELT, the CELT criterion, it was not just that you had to be overall level four or five on the CELT.
You also had to have all of your domain scores at intermediate or above.
So we explored looking at the composite domain scores, if those were higher.
So you were LPEC level four and you were four in the oral and in the written composite scores and so on.
And basically, we found a bit of an increase, but really there was still no difference.
It was not consistent.
And particularly grades 7, 8, and 11, you couldn't make up the difference.
You just saw that even though they were at these more rigorous levels on LPAC-4, their performance on Smarter Balanced was not really showing a difference.
So basically, the takeaway is that our findings, based on these multiple analyses,
really paralleled what Patty Barron was just sharing with her contrasting group studies, which suggests that the performance threshold for level four needs to be raised because kids are, through these multiple sources of evidence, teachers are saying that they're rating lower than what the test is saying.
We're seeing the performance of students at level four where you expect them to have at least an equal chance, an equal likelihood of performing proficient on Smarter Balanced or approximating the monolingual English speaker kids, but it was not happening.
So, I'll answer any clarification questions you have on this.
Thank you, Robert.
I just want to say congratulations on distilling this information in a way that was very digestible.
When I first read this item, I thought it was one of those items I could read at 11 o'clock at night before I went to bed.
And I picked it up.
I'm like, oh, no.
This is not going to happen.
I need fresh eyes for this.
So there was a lot of information.
But I just want to give kudos to Michelle, Dr. Barron, everybody that's here, Veronica, obviously, Aguila.
I was able to participate in the standard setting workshop and just the thorough process that goes behind this assessment and identifying cut scores and making sure that we're doing the contrast work
I, you know, I was very impressed by it.
I'm impressed by it.
I think that it just shows our dedication to making sure that what we're putting out there is going to be of service and equity for students because we want to make sure we get it right.
Right.
This could be high stakes for some of our students.
So I just want to thank you.
I want to thank you for providing this information in a way that's very tangible.
I thought it was a very technical item, but I think it was presented well.
Thank you.
I, too, would like to thank you and thank all of the staff for doing the work that you're doing and the tools and the resources that you have provided in addition to what we're talking about right now.
I think that what we are doing really is the long term vision of what we want LPAC to be able to do, that we can have this confidence in if they're at this level, they'll perform this way.
And there's this alignment.
And I think we've been
looking for that for a long time, so we really celebrate the findings, if you will, and we appreciate the in-depth and the multiple points.
And we want to make sure that the teachers who were involved in the contrast study, that they're validated, if you will, in terms of the input that they gave to this study.
So thank you very much.
So following those two studies, we started our conversations at CDE.
The CDE consulted with the LPAC Technical Advisory Group and with national experts from WIDA and ALPA 21 to seek input on the results within the California context and also provide the CDE with a national perspective of common practices across states.
Additional briefings were held with members of the Bilingual Coordinators Network, Californians Together, as well as the California Association for Bilingual Education to make sure that all of these groups had an understanding of the proposal that we're presenting to you today.
Based on the information that was gathered, the CDE is recommending changing grade span thresholds for grade spans 3 through 5 and 6 through 8 to individual grade level thresholds.
On the next two slides, we have provided you with the estimated percentages of students in each LPAC performance level in kindergarten through grade 12.
The majority of threshold scores at each level increased.
The goal was to make minor changes to the threshold scores at the composite level in order to honor the intent of the standard setting panels work while also taking into consideration the data from the two studies that were presented to you.
As a reminder, according to the LPAC performance level descriptors, students who are at level four have well-developed oral and written skills and perform at the upper range of the bridging proficiency level.
With these proposed threshold scores, the CDE is increasing the rigor of the LPAC.
As an example, let's look at the performance of a fifth grade student on CELT and LPAC in the last two years compared to the estimated percentage of students who will meet level four of the new threshold scores that are before you.
So that's the last row here.
So if we went to DataQuest,
and looked at the number of fifth grade students identified as meeting the 16-17 California English Language Proficiency Test or CELT criterion, that was 49% in 2016-17.
On the 2017-18 threshold scores that were approved by you in November, on that LPAC, which measured California's new, more rigorous English language proficiency standards, that dropped to 31% of fifth grade students meeting level four.
Now, as you can see on this slide, you can see that the estimated percentage of fifth grade students meeting level four using the threshold scores before you will be approximately 17%.
I'm making you aware of this to emphasize the increased rigor with the proposed level four threshold scores.
This ensures that students at this level are more likely to perform in the upper range of bridging, which is what the description is in terms of the expectation, as well as more likely to score at level three on the Smarter Balanced ELA assessment.
Here are the estimated percentage of students in each LPAC performance level in 6 through 12.
Please note that for 9 and 10 and 11 and 12, we did not split those out into individual grade spans because there was minimal difference in the performance of students between those grades.
Once approved, these recommended threshold scores will be implemented with the 2018-19 administration.
The 2018-19 summative LPAC threshold scores will inform further supplemental empirical analyses by the California Comprehensive Center so that the English Learner Support Division can bring forward to you, hopefully in January, new English language proficiency criterion for reclassification.
In addition, the CDE has been in a recruitment phrase for educators to participate in an initial LPAC threshold score validation review that will occur in fall.
If changes are required to the initial LPAC threshold scores, they are anticipated to be brought to the board in March of 2019 for incorporation into the 2019-20 LPAC.
So hopefully that summarized the recommendation before you today.
Would the following speakers please line up at the podium?
Doug McRae, Martha Diaz.
Good morning, I'm Doug McGray, a retired testing specialist.
The 2018 LPAC threshold scores approved by the State Board last November are a mess and as detailed in the material that I gave to the electronic folder last week.
The CDE plan for addressing this problem will delay use of LPAC scores for the dashboard at least until 2020, which was addressed last July, and potentially two or three additional years.
There's a better way to address this problem.
First, rescore the 2018 LPAC raw data using revised threshold scores now being recommended.
and use these rescaled results as baseline for the 2019 dashboard so you don't delay it a year.
Second, execute a rigorous comparability study in the spring or summer of 2020 when LPAC is scheduled for transition from paper and pencil to computer administered.
To allow the 2020 scores to be comparable to the 2018 and 2019, these two changes will permit English language proficiency component to be published not only on the 2019 dashboard, but also for years going forward.
Thank you.
Good morning, Martha Zaragoza-Diaz representing the California Association for Bilingual Education and Californians Together.
I too wish to thank Michelle and her staff for taking the time to explain to me and to others in CABE and Caltog this very complicated process in terms of how all the CUT scores were achieved.
We do, however, continue to have three major concerns.
Having to wait until 2020 for EL data for purposes of the EL PI and dashboard is very problematic.
There is another approach that can give us EL data in 2019.
that is to rescore the 2018 LPAC data as baseline for 2019 gain scores as outlined in Mr. McRae's letter on page five, which you all have.
I would request that the board ask the staff to take a look at its viability.
Our second concern is that TK data is included in the kindergarten data for purposes of determining cut scores for kindergarten.
While TK, can I continue?
While TK is considered the first year of a two-year kindergarten program, it uses a modified age and developmentally appropriate kindergarten curriculum aligned to the California Preschool Learning Foundations developed by CDE.
We must not judge TK children
having the same as kindergarten children.
Thank you.
Oh, we request that the TK data be disaggregated from the kindergarten data for cut score purposes.
Just wanted to address two things.
One, yesterday I think we made it rather clear that we will be using 2018-2019 LPI data to identify schools.
So for the LPIC, for the LPI indicator, sorry, sorry, all the acronyms.
So we will be using it for accountability purposes.
That's something that I feel we're all very committed to.
The second comment that was made, I think it's really just a general discussion and also in terms of the TK, there's a divide in the field in terms of EL advocate supporters, in terms of how TK should or should not be used.
So, there is the camp that feels that it's too soon and it's aligned to the
preschool learning foundations, which happens to be aligned to the ELD and Common Core.
By Ed Code, it is year one of a two-year program.
And the divide is really, let's test them, let's try to get intervention and support for our students as early, or let's wait until kinder, right?
I think because it is an Ed Code that this is a one of two-year program,
I think it's appropriate to keep it in kinder, but I do think that we need to look and see are we reclassifying, is our students in kinder reaching that level four, which is one of four points of criteria for reclassification.
I think we do need to monitor that a little bit more because there is some concern that we may be prematurely reclassifying students in the very early grades.
So that is something that I feel we need to monitor more closely.
Thank you.
I move the department's recommendation.
Next.
And so we have no changes pulled.
Oh, we have recusals though.
All right.
And so we're going to have proposed waiver consent calendar includes W1 through W9.
And we have recusal by
Member Rucker who's refused.
Okay, we can vote on that.
W-1 only.
Okay.
So we will then vote on W-1.
I need a motion and a second for W-1.
Okay.
Any public comment?
Paula?
No public comment.
Okay.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, now we're going to do W2 through 9.
Okay, now we're ready for waivers 2 through 9 with no recusals.
No public comment.
Do I have a motion?
Is there any public comment?
No public comment.
Okay.
All those in favor.
Second.
It was seconded by board member Sandoval.
All those in favor, raise your hand.
Okay.
And now we have the consent items.
Yeah, the first consent item is item 10.
Sue will recuse.
And Feliza will recuse.
That's what I have.
Item 10.
You must recuse.
Okay.
All right.
So we're on item... Yeah, we're on item 10.
So we're going to vote only on 10.
Yeah, which is the OMI.
Okay.
All right.
So I have a motion on item 10.
Wait a minute.
We're voting on item 10.
We're voting on part of item 10.
So it's item 10 CONAP number 33 only.
We need a motion for that.
Okay.
Item 10 CONAP.
Item 10 number 33.
Okay.
Okay, this is for item one, number 33 only.
And okay, I think we ought to have a motion again.
So moved.
Okay, all those in favor of Item 1, Attachment Waiver Attachment 1, Number 33.
All raise your hands.
Item 10.
Okay, now we have the second consent vote.
Now we have the second part of Item 10.
Okay, now these are all the items remaining on Item 10.
Right.
The board will now be voting on the remaining CON apps listed in attachment one.
All right.
Do I have a motion for that?
Any public comment?
No public comment.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay.
That does the...
Now we're on items 13 through 18.
These are the consent votes.
This is a consent calendar 13 through 18.
We have... Is there any public comment on this?
No public comment.
All right.
I need a motion.
I will move the consent.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
Okay, we're going to take a break then till 1025 and we'll then hear the charter item.
Thank you.
Board will reconvene and we're on item 19 and petition for the establishment of a charter school, Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
Lisa Casanzo will present for the department and then we'll have our public hearing.
All right, good morning everyone.
Item number 19 is for Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy and it is a petition before the State Board for an establishment of a school under the authorization of the State Board of Education.
June 12, 2018, the San Francisco Unified School District voted to deny the petition of Mariel Booker Leadership Academy by a vote of six to zero.
The San Francisco Unified School District Board of Education acts on behalf of the city and the county of San Francisco.
Therefore, the petition was then submitted directly to the State Board of Education.
The petitioner submitted the petition on appeal to the State Board on July 27th of 2018.
CDE staff recommendation is that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy, a 6-12 charter school, under the oversight of the State Board of Education with the following conditions.
Evidence that the Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy has received the funding anticipated from each of the commitment letters that they have identified, and that the Academy will provide the CDE with a revised 2019-20 budget.
CD's recommendation is based on a sound educational program, that the petition is demonstratively likely to successfully implement the program, provided the petitioner again secures the funding as stated, and that there is a reasonably comprehensive description of most of the charter elements.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools met on October 9th, 2018.
The Advisory Commission voted to move staff's recommendation to the State Board of Education and the motion passed unanimously by a vote of nine to zero.
Mario Booker Leadership Academy intends to open in 1920, serving first grades 6 through 8.
And they're proposing to enroll 120 students in those grade levels.
They're proposing to grow a grade per year to serve grades 6 through 12 by the end of the term in 2023-24, with a total of 420 students by that point.
A little background on the facility, the deadline to submit Prop 39 requests to the district was November 1st.
We have spoken to the petitioner and they have requested a school in the Bayview Mission, Visitation Valley zip code areas of the district.
And as part of the Prop 39 request to the district, they have submitted 400 meaningful intent forms as part of their Prop 39 application.
In terms of their educational program, the mission of the school is to develop the next generation of diverse leaders in San Francisco by preparing graduates to be successful leaders in college and career through a rigorous, people-centered academic program and a shared belief in leadership, equity, and community.
The petition states that the Leadership Academy is grounded with three core values, community, equity, and leadership, with three primary outcomes for its graduates, college and career ready, community connection, and leadership development.
The petition, the school is proposing to locate and serve pupils primarily from the southeast San Francisco neighborhoods of Bayview and Mission.
The projected demographics that are in this chart and in the slide have been pulled directly from the petition.
Each of the board members, you also have attachment to
And that attachment just shows the comparable schools in the district and the similar demographics to those other schools in attachment to.
They are pretty similar to what the petitioner has stated they're going to project outreach for in that community.
They are pretty similar.
In terms of the ability to implement the program and the fiscal analysis, the initial review, the multi-year financial plan was not fiscally viable.
And we have been consistent with what we've been doing with the previous petitions.
We do take out what we deem to be those soft costs.
So revenues included the new school venture fund for $215,000 and Silicon School Fund for $250,000.
We did work with the petitioner.
We have some updated financials in terms of additional commitment letters that they've received.
And so on top of those amounts in the previous slide, the new school venture fund is also committing to additional $455,000 upon authorization that would be spread over a three-year period.
Silicon School Fund is also committing to an additional $635,000 spread over a three-year period.
So we feel that our fiscal concerns have been addressed provided that, again, this funding is received.
Our recommendation does include submission of a revised budget and a multi-year financial plan to include these additional commitment letters and how they will be dispersed over the five-year term.
In terms of deficiencies in the charter elements, if the petition is approved by the state board, the following charter elements need to be clarified by the petitioner.
So in terms of measurable people outcomes, the petition does not include measurable outcomes for each of the specific subgroups, so we do want to see some clarification in that area.
They also in the annual independent financial audit did not identify who's responsible for contracting and overseeing the independent audit.
And then in terms of expulsion and suspension procedures, we do need some updates again with the new law and we have been seeing this consistently with the petitions that have come forward.
So these are some elements in the charter petition that are not material, but we do want to see revisions to if this petition does go forward as a state board authorized school.
In summary, CDE staff is recommending approval for a sound educational program, overall fiscal viability, and clarification of the charter elements in the petition that we feel are needed.
I am available now for any questions you may have, the petitioners here and the school district as well.
Do we have any technical questions before we run the public hearing?
Yes, technical questions.
I actually just have a clarification.
You said that they plan to open in 2020 and it was 2019-20.
I'm sorry, did I say that?
I apologize.
19-20.
Yes, the coming school year.
My mistake.
Okay.
Any other?
All right.
If not, I'll open the public hearing.
Each side will have ten minutes.
And so we will start with the proponents of the petition to open the charter school and then have the opponents with ten minutes.
Please come forward.
Can I begin?
Good morning, commissioners.
My name is Terrence Davis, and I'm the school founder of Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
School founder Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy, a 6th through 12th grade charter school, planning to open in Southeast San Francisco in 2019.
We'll start with grades 6, 7, and 8.
Our school is founded on three core values, our commitment to the community, our belief that every single student has the ability to learn, and the fact that we see our school as a group of people that are going to develop the next great generation of leaders.
Before going into our school model, I want to first talk, I want to acknowledge the CDE's review.
We appreciate the thorough review and the communication that's happened, and the city staff just talked about that.
We plan to go along with any of the deficiencies that were addressed, and we will continue to work with the staff.
In addition, I want to acknowledge the ACCS vote for approval.
Again, we appreciate the time we were able to meet after as a group, and there was a lot of great feedback that we plan to implement into our school model.
So going into today, there's a couple of things that we're going to talk about.
We'll talk about our school model.
We'll do a little bit of work around our community involvement.
But I recognize that a part of today is my capacity as a school leader.
So a little bit about me.
I've been in education for the last 10 years, fortunate enough to work at high-performing schools, both the High Tech High, which is based in San Diego, and the Noble Network in Chicago.
It was at these schools that I recognized the power of finding some of the best elements of these high-performing schools.
While I was doing this at the same time, I also recognized that there's areas that we can improve.
And I started getting this idea and this dream of developing a school.
In addition to being an educator, I'm also a father and a husband.
My wife and two boys are here.
I think they're in the overflow room, because they're too small right now to sit through this whole presentation.
But it was about four or five years ago, as my youngest son was about to be born, that I started with this idea of wanting to develop the school, as I mentioned.
My wife and I had kept talking to her and mentioned this idea of a school, and eventually she's the one that encouraged me to take a step of faith and try to go with this dream of building a school.
When I had this, I was at the same time I connected with a couple of organizations, Innovate Public Schools and Silicon School Fund, who at the same time were looking to support someone like myself in launching a school.
So again, I've been in education for 10 years, but I recognize I still wanted to get more leadership experience.
So I spent another year at a school in Hayward as a principal in residence, focusing on all the different aspects I would need to make sure that our school was successful.
At the same time, I was spending nights going to coffee shops, meeting with families, and talking about this idea of building a school.
Many of the people you'll see behind me that will have a chance to speak are part of what we've called our design team.
Our design team is made up of parents and community members who have been with me throughout this process in developing Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
It was in these meetings in San Francisco, specifically in the Bayview, in the Mission and Visitation Valley, that I recognized how important it could be to develop a school in this community.
Again, I mentioned you'll see our design team was developed in June of 2017.
Again, they've been a part of every element of this school, from the naming of the school, the mission statement, to the elements of the school model that you'll see a little later.
I want to take time to acknowledge those that are behind me in the black shirts.
This is a picture of a naming ceremony we had in the winter of 2017.
where we came together to talk about how we can develop this high-performing school.
During these meetings, not only did we meet to talk about what the school would look like, we also looked at data.
In San Francisco, specifically the communities that we're trying to serve, 1 in 10 African-American students are at grade level for math and English.
2 out of 10 Latino students are at grade level for math and English.
When we go on this map that's in front of you, you'll see the distribution of high quality schools concentrated on the west side of the city, the communities we hope to serve.
As you see, there's plenty of red and yellow dots indicating that there's not as many school options for the families we hope to serve.
The next step we took was to get out into the community and to go out and collect the signatures to make sure that we have the support for the school.
As was stated before, our team has collected since the start of January 2018, we've collected over 400 signatures for families that have students that can go to our school.
We know that this is only the first step.
This is just students and parents saying that they are intent to enroll.
We know the next step which starts for us on November 12th on Monday is starting to get them enrolled and officially into the school once we get our approval.
But we feel like this is a good indication of the amount of support families have for having a high quality option.
I'll also point out this heat map corresponds to the pictures that you saw before in terms of where we've collected these signatures.
So into the school model, what are students going to be doing on a daily basis?
I mentioned before, our core values are community, equity, and leadership.
We start off with our dream team.
Our dream team consists of the student, parent, teacher, but what we add is any important person and any important adult in a student's life.
That could be a grandparent, it could be a basketball coach, it could be a pastor, a mentor, whoever is important and will help that student in their progress.
The example that I give is that I've worked a lot with students, especially as they start to get older in high school.
Sometimes it's the parent that can have the great connection that could be the one to get them motivated.
We also know there's other people.
There's other people that can help motivate them.
And so the big thing with our dream team is make sure everyone's on the same page.
The next in time of the daily schedule and what it's going to look like, we have three core beliefs.
First and foremost, we believe every student has a capacity to learn.
We know that it is our job to develop proficient readers, writers, and mathematicians.
And we want to make sure that every single day students are making a personal connection to the work that they have.
So what does that look like?
We start with our leadership class.
Our leadership class is 30 minutes, Monday through Thursday, where students are going through a social-emotional curriculum that we've adopted from a school in Tennessee called Valor Collegiate.
On Friday, they come together to do circles, which are very similar to the restorative justice practice that we plan to implement.
So what we think that is going to be unique about our school, because I know restorative justice comes up, our students are going to be doing this every single day.
And then on Fridays, we're going to be practicing these skills.
So if there is a conflict, students are used to resolving them.
We don't want to bring our restorative practices after there's a fight or after there's a big issue.
We want it to be a part of our school model.
The next part, I talked about how do we develop proficient readers, writers, and mathematicians.
Our learning studios, our small group instruction, where we're having students in classes of 5 to 10, focus on their individual needs, moving at their pace so that they're getting what they need to be successful.
The last part of our day, which is a very important part, which is the bulk of the day, is our core time.
This is when we infuse our project-based learning.
I mentioned before, I had initially worked at High Tech High, which is well known for their project-based learning work.
Actually, where I had my curriculum, not curriculum, my credential.
My credential came from High Tech High and through their project-based learning method.
So we believe this is the time that after students are getting that individual support, when we go to the larger classrooms, they're working on group projects, long-term assignments.
And the big thing with this time is that we give students multiple ways to demonstrate mastery.
So we know that all students don't demonstrate their mastery in the same way.
So this is the time where they'll be able to have more freedom when selecting their projects and more personalization.
I close on this picture because it's always been pretty profound for me.
This is a workshop we did about two months ago with a father and son.
What we did is, it was very simple.
We had two sets of batteries, an LED bulb, and a lot of different materials, paper clips, any type of material that we can use.
And the task was to take the batteries, the materials, and to create that light.
Part of that is an example, a little brief window into what a project-based learning approach is.
The other part is it's just showing the development of how we can look to work together.
I use this example in part because the families in this room, many of them are here today, all spoke Spanish.
I do not speak Spanish.
I'm working on it.
I always say un poquito, right?
But despite the fact that I wasn't as strong with Spanish, and we were working on this project, we were all able to work together because there's so many ways that we can connect.
We can work together to find the materials, to point out the solutions.
And we were talking together, and the parents were helping each other out.
And so I look at this picture as kind of what my role is.
My role, very simply, is to help every student find their way to light their own light.
My role is with their parents to make sure that they are on the same page and they know what's going on with their students and they know that their students are being challenged.
And I close in saying that my role, along with that, is to make sure that we are staying connected to the community members that have been supporting us.
Again, I'll give time for people to speak after me, but I can't say how overwhelmed I've been by the amount of people that have come out to support our school.
And we are so proud of the amount of work we've done to get Mariel Booker Leadership Academy to this point.
We are excited for November 12th, because that is
Monday, right?
Next week, right?
Where we can move forward and start with the progress of Open Our School in 2019.
I look forward to any questions and thank you for your time.
Thank you.
All right, we're now ready for the opponents to the petition.
They have 10 minutes.
That's for your patient.
Was yours password protected?
Looks good.
Is it there?
Good morning President Kerst and board members, if it is indeed still morning.
My name is Michael Davis.
I'm the Director of Policy and Planning and Charter Schools for San Francisco Unified School District.
And I'm here to present to you, once again, our findings regarding the Mary L. Booker charter petition and ask you to make a finding in our favor.
So first, I'd like to give you a little background.
So San Francisco Unified School District currently has about 57,000 students.
Of that 57,000 students, there are about 6,500
enrolled in charter schools.
Of that 6,500, 2,500 are in the San Francisco authorized five keys charter schools that were established by the San Francisco County Sheriff's Department and so they serve 2,500 kids roughly all over the state of California.
The other 4,000 are in traditional TK through 12 settings in San Francisco operated by charter schools.
There are a total of 17 charter schools operating in San Francisco right now.
14 of those are authorized by the San Francisco Unified School District Board, and three of them are authorized by your board.
Of those 17 schools, the three that are authorized by your board that are operating in San Francisco are housed in San Francisco Unified District facilities under the provisions of Proposition 39.
And then we have another nine schools that we authorize that are in our facilities as well.
Here's the timeline, which has already been shared ad nauseum, so you know what that is.
The petition was submitted to us on April 24, 2018, denied on June 12, unanimously.
Our board approved the recommendation of staff, which was to deny the petition.
It was submitted to you on July 27th.
And the advisory commission voted on October 9th to forward a recommendation to you to hold a public hearing and approve the charter as a school under your oversight.
So under the law for
review of charter petitions by local boards in California.
We take our
responsibility very seriously and spend a great deal of staff time and effort to do a proper review of the petition.
So we have what's called our Charter Petition Review Committee.
It's comprised of our Chief Academic Officer, Chief of Student, Family, and Community Support, myself, our Chief of Human Resources, Chief Financial Officer,
an assistant superintendent that has responsibility for the type of school the charter is proposing, our executive director of counseling and post-secondary success, director of multilingual pathways, director of creativity and the arts.
The findings of this committee are reviewed and heard by our Board of Education's Curriculum and Program Committee, our Board of Education Budget and Business Services Committee, and finally, the staff recommendation is heard by the full Board of Education.
On June 12, 2018,
The staff made a recommendation to our board to deny the MLBLA petition.
The reasons were the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the charter provisions outlined in the Ed Code and the petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition.
We have provided you, the CDE staff, and yourselves with our extensive analysis of how we came to these findings and why we asked our board to adopt these findings for denial.
Under the not containing the reasonably comprehensive descriptions, we found that the petition fails to set forth reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all required charter elements as required by Ed Code 47605.
Specifically, the elements of a high quality instructional program are not adequately defined.
The petition does not contain a sufficient description of the procedures by which students can be suspended or expelled.
The petitioner inadequately defines the training that would produce the teaching skills required.
And the petitioners appeared not to have adequate technical backing and support.
And both Innovate and the petition appear to lack this subject matter expertise.
So why do we say that?
There are several findings that we made in our review of the petition that found it did not meet the requirements as outlined in law.
Further, on the issue of the capacity to carry out the program, we had some serious concerns.
And those were that there's a lack of school governance experience.
The experience of the founding leader does not provide the background meeting the experience and qualifications cited in the petition.
Innovate and the lead petitioner have not demonstrated the capacity to successfully operate a charter school and inadequate demonstration of community support.
So on the lack of school experience,
Innovate has done a lot of work in the communities lately, meeting with people, doing analyses, pointing out the deficiencies in certain schools in local school districts.
What Innovate has not done successfully yet is open and operate a charter school.
For example, in September, this board agreed to allow the Promise Academy sponsored by Innovate to open a year later than initially planned.
That was after approving that charter petition a year earlier.
in spite of a negative recommendation from CDE staff and from the local school district and approving it by eliminating the high school portion of the petition of the proposed program.
So, after doing all that to allow the school to be approved
even though it did not merely meet the requirements for approval, then the school still had to come back and ask for another year in order to open.
We don't think that that indicates a high likelihood of success by the sponsors of that petition or the Mary L. Booker petition.
Let's talk about community support.
The petition as it was submitted to San Francisco Unified School District relied on signatures from meaningfully interested teachers.
There were no signatures of meaningfully interested parents submitted.
That was the same thing that happened with the Kipp Elementary School, which this board approved after we denied.
And that Kipp Elementary School recently had to cut back its projection of enrollment for this current year from 140 to 102.
They're only getting 70% of what they said.
So this school comes in with the same apparent initial lack of community support and intends to operate in the same geographic area as the Kipp Elementary School, which was recently approved and started to operate.
We recently received the Prop 39 request from Marielle Booker on the November 1st deadline.
I've started to review that.
I think that it includes about 150 parent signatures.
And so please correct me if I'm wrong, if I'm missing something.
I have not seen anywhere a demonstration of 400 parent signatures as stated in the prior presentations.
So that's a concern we have as well.
Further, the CDE review found that the petition does not present reasonably comprehensive description of measurable pupil outcomes.
It does not present a reasonably comprehensive description of suspension expulsion, does not present a reasonably comprehensive description of annual independent financial audit, and does not meet the requirements to address the goals to address the eight state priorities.
Now, CDE staff presentation did address those.
So in summary, we would ask that you respect the lawful legal procedures as carried out responsibly by the local school district and not place another charter school under your distant oversight in our boundaries.
Thank you.
First public comment.
Okay.
We will now close the public hearing and open it up for public comment.
All right.
Would the first group of individuals please sign up at the podium?
Sheila Whitley, Julie Roberts-Fung, Diane Gray, Rosa Rhodes, Alma Fisker, Martha Bruder, Ebony Scott,
C. McElroy, Valerie Bell, Keega Beals-Lee, and Elizabeth Alma.
Please come forward.
First person on the list, please come forward.
Repeat the list.
Sheila Whitley, Julie Roberts-Fung, Diane Gray, Rosa Rhodes, Alma Fisker, Martha Bruder, Ebony Scott, C. McElroy, Valerie Bell, Keega Bealsley, and Elizabeth Alma.
Okay, go ahead.
Sheila Whitley on behalf of the California Teachers Association.
I urge the State Board to reject the petition of Mary Booker Academy.
There are many reasons this board should not overturn well-reasoned decisions made at the local level.
Three of those reasons include the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive descriptions of all of the charter provisions outlined in Ed Code.
It is lacking information on meeting the needs of ELD and students with disabilities.
The petitioners are unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition.
And the third thing is the petition does not designate an entity or individual who is responsible for closure-related activities as required by law.
By allowing the school to open, it would set children up for failure.
CTA is deeply committed to the success of every student and we urge you to reject this charter school petition.
Thank you.
Yes, I should remind you that each speaker has one minute.
Please come forward.
Hello, I have letters here from educators in San Francisco.
So I don't know who I should give those to.
Good morning.
My name is Diane Gray.
I am the San Francisco Commissioner for the Southeast Community Facility Commission and the Executive Director of 100% College Prep, a college prep program in the Bayview-Hunters Point community.
I grew up in that community.
I've been a homeowner there for over 20 years.
I am speaking against Innovate's Mary L. Booker Charter.
This charter school request is to be named after one of our community treasures and legends who stood for civil rights and demonstrated that through the performing arts.
There is no reference to this mission or Mario Booker's mission, I should say, or vision in this charter position petition.
There is no such innovation in this model.
The process for design and development was not a fully community process where all indigenous community members... Time.
Thank you.
I just want to say that in our greater southeast community, there are already six schools that are serving middle school to high school.
We don't need a new school.
No innovation there.
Thank you.
Hello, board.
I'm Ross Rhodes, not Rosie Rhodes.
And I'm part of Mrs. Gray Afterschool Program, the 100% College Prep Club.
Now, I'm here.
I don't have anything to read or anything to tell you about why I'm here.
I'm here because I'm looking at corporate America infusing itself in our public schools.
It's time to kick the can.
We are the can.
We are the public schools.
what's going to make our schools work is what we do here.
Everybody here is for a reason.
We want a better education for our kids.
The only way we get a better education for our kids is to step into the schools and make these things happen, not by us just sitting here and saying, oh, well, we think that this charter school thing will work.
Well, this is money that is going out of the
public schools.
What are we going to be?
A pipeway for charter schools to kick out the kids they don't want, and then they come back to the public schools, and then we do the pathway from public schools to prisons?
What are we going to do?
We're going to stand here and we have to make the decisions, the right decisions, to empower our public schools.
Time.
It's important.
Please.
Listen.
It's important.
Hi.
My name is Elizabeth Parasol.
I'm a proud parent of five children at MXA, Malcolm X Academy.
I'm here to talk about sharing our school with a charter school.
You guys allowed charter into our school, and now we have to deal with the consequences.
When the inconvenience of sharing our school took place at MXA Charter,
stated that they would have higher enrollment but currently have 30% lower enrollment while MXA has 40% higher enrollment.
You approved charter schools and now we are suffering because they're trashing our school.
Our schools and students are going in and out of charter schools to our public schools as we speak.
How inconvenient is that?
What are we showing our children?
It is okay to be unstable.
Do you think it's okay to do this to another school?
But as a Bayview parent, I am here to say, no, it's not okay.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Kia Beasley, and I am a proud parent of two students at Malcolm X Academy.
Currently, Innovate does not have parents to support their petitions.
And you guys are offering them over $500,000 to
have access to, excuse me, you're offering them over $500,000.
And if we put that $500,000 towards our public schools, we will be able to do improvements.
And I'm telling you, you would see the enrollment increasing.
Goodness, my nerves.
Sorry.
You would see those numbers increasing.
I also work for the district.
I took off to be here because I am a public school parent.
And Malcolm X is also a pitch school.
And we're suffering.
Our teachers are doing as much as they can to support us as parents.
And I just ask that you guys really look into it and do your jobs.
We appreciate you.
Good morning.
My name is Valerie Bell.
I have a fourth grader attending Malcolm X Academy.
He's an IEP student.
And Malcolm X, the programs that Malcolm X provide outside of the programs offered are a mentoring program, a math studies program, and a reading program.
Those programs are currently funded by our teachers out of their own pocket.
This is a public school, not a charter school.
A particular teacher has put everything into mentoring and teaching my son and the outcome was tremendous.
Malcolm X Academy has been a great help to me to helping my son.
And so we need to invest in our community and not into charter schools.
Thank you for your time.
Hello, I'm Ebony Scott.
I'm also a proud parent at Malcolm X Academy.
I would just like to say that if you're going to start a new school, then you need a principal that's experienced.
You know, the school that we come from, they love us.
Everyone in there is experienced.
We have experienced teachers, experienced everything in there.
and you want to start a new school, we don't want a new school.
And another thing, I never signed any petition and I am an intricate part of my community in San Francisco in the Bayview District and I've never seen no petitions.
I've never seen one petition and I never signed one petition.
And like I said, I'm an intricate part of that community.
I volunteer in that community.
Our schools are great.
We don't need new schools.
We don't, that's not what we need there.
We need for you to put money into our public schools and help our children grow versus putting new schools in there.
We already have schools.
We need experienced principals in our schools, period.
Thank you.
Good morning commissioners.
My name is Alida Fisher.
I'm the chair of the Community Advisory Committee for Special Education in the SFUSD SELPA and a proud parent of four students within SFUSD.
And I appreciate the fact that we're talking about the quality of our schools in the southeast.
You know, I can recognize why some of the narratives that have been told are gaining traction.
And in fact, I've met with Mr. Davis and I really appreciate his willing to reach out into the community and
It's so hard for me to sit here and be face-to-face with parents and see so much hostility and animosity when all we want is improved outcomes for our kids.
That's all we want.
It doesn't matter if you're African-American.
It doesn't matter if you've got an IEP.
We all want the best.
I firmly believe that's not through charter schools.
The fact that the petition was presented to the school district on April 24th, yet Mr. Davis told me on the
on the, in May that we wanted, they were interested in joining the SELPA.
That's not what was in the petition.
There's disconnect somewhere.
I don't, I think we all need to be doing some pretty serious review of the data and disconnect.
Thank you.
Come forward please.
With the following speakers, please line up at the podium.
Melissa Caraval, Karen Medina, Eugenia Mayerall, Adrian Adamkovic, Pastor Walker, Cynthia Segura.
Please come forward.
My name is Julie Roberts Fung.
I'm a public school parent in the Tenderloin in San Francisco.
And I'm really concerned that this board is going to approve a charter and then in San Francisco we're going to have to deal with the ramifications of that.
And I think you heard from Malcolm X families about what has happened in their school last year.
My concerns about Mary L. Booker, it's great to see so many Mary L. Booker parents here, working so hard, wanting so much for their children, and I'm concerned that they're going to need to use that advocacy within their schools, and that they won't have the rights that parents have in public schools.
The San Francisco school district denied this charter because there was not sufficient due process for expulsions and suspensions.
The school founder is a nice man, but he is not certified, and his experience comes from a charter school.
where students were told to put their hands up and do a code zero and be silent in the classroom, largely students of color by largely white teachers.
So I want you to understand that your decisions here today create problems for families in San Francisco.
I also want to speak to the fact that a parent came here today and was turned away from testifying because she didn't bring an ID with her.
And I want to know why, for a public meeting, we are asking parents who may be undocumented or not have access to IDs
to show their ideas before they get their voices heard.
That policy needs to change and you all need to email your legislators to ask for that to happen.
Honorable board members, I'm Dr. Aurelius Walker, pastor of the True Hope Church of God in Christ in Bayview, Hunters Point, also a member of the Tabernacle Community Development Corporation, about 10 churches with that faith-based group.
Also, the Clergy Caucus, a new group of clergy, we are forming.
We have 10 members, 10 churches.
Also, our goal is to get about 50 churches, and we are working on that.
We are very disturbed.
We are very disturbed about the lack of education for the African Americans in San Francisco by the Board of Education, for the lack of educating the Latinos, lack of educating the Pacific Islanders.
We are a diverse group of clergy and faith community members who were first brought together by the efforts of a local family and community of innovative public.
We firmly believe in carrying out the legacy of our diverse faith, our tradition, Christian, Catholic, and we are determined, and we ask you by all means, would you be so kind to approve the Mary L. Brooker Leadership Academy.
Thanks very much.
Please come forward.
Hi, my name is Karen Medina.
I am here today to tell you about my experiences in San Francisco public schools and how they shaped me to who I am today.
I went to James Lake Middle School, which provided many programs and resources, which included SPARK, a program that interned with someone from a corporation to get ideas of what career you wanted to do when you grew up.
I also went to Galileo, which had lots of programs, resources, such as dance, music, science, science club, peer resources, robotics, and AVID.
AVID is the program which helped me get into college.
It helped me with my classes, letters of recommendation, and offered tutoring in all subjects.
Due to these resources I am now a student at San Francisco State University going on my third year.
I am also a first generation student.
I am the first in my family to graduate high school and will be the first to graduate college.
My hope is to work in public schools as a speech therapist but by allowing charter schools to take funds from public schools that won't be possible.
So please reject this unnecessary and inadequate charter school.
It will divide our community and will take resources and opportunities away from our students.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Eugenia Mayoral.
I'm the mother of one student of this public school, Willie Brown.
The school is excellent.
They've helped a lot, my kid, my son.
They've had no problems at all, either with the teachers or with his peers.
He's an excellent in his grades.
And in this last year, they found diabetes.
The teachers and social workers and nurse have helped him a lot with the 504 plan.
And they've helped him with his diabetes and support him.
And the school has a lot of programs, good programs, and my son practices baseball.
We don't want that the schools, that the public school, we don't want that the charter schools take money from the public schools.
Because they are taking out opportunities from our sons, from the public schools.
Because my sons and daughters have benefited a lot from public schools.
I ask this board to say no to this new charter school and help the current public schools.
Thank you very much.
Eugenia.
Hello, my name is Arian Adam Chikova, and I'm a credentialed public school teacher in the state of California with 17 years of experience and a master's in education from Stanford University.
Our school board in San Francisco rejected the Marielle Booker charter petition because of the weaknesses in its programs, including its lack of clear discipline procedures.
The charter names restorative practices,
However, I have to reject the idea that this school leadership will be able to implement such practices.
Restorative practices take years of training and experience to implement well.
Our progressive school district is comprised of people that have led the country in implementing restorative practices across its middle and high schools.
My son went through restorative practices every day and community circles every Friday in his three years as a student at Everett Middle School in the city.
This school is not innovative in that.
Our school district has longevity and expertise in restorative practices and restorative justice and continues working to improve its practice each day.
However, many of us are concerned about this particular charter leader's background in restorative practices.
He may need to work closely with SFUSD to understand how it's done.
Please reject this charter.
They have not done due diligence and they're dividing our community.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Cynthia Segura.
I'm a mother of two students in the SFUSD School District.
One is currently at Lowell High School.
And another one is in the first year at San Francisco State University.
A pesar de que mis dos hijas han sido creadas por mí, que soy una misma persona, ellas dos son diferentes.
Y me pude dar cuenta de que ellas necesitaban diferente forma de educación.
Despite both being raised by myself, both daughters, I've noticed through schooling, needed different things from school.
Me refiero a la que está Lowell.
Ella pude ver que ella tenía la gran capacidad de lidiar con una escuela grande y el empuje por ella misma.
My daughter, who's currently at Lowell, I could tell that she could make it at a larger school and had the will within herself to make it at a larger school.
But my other daughter, she needed more attention.
She needed a smaller setting, which is why I chose to put her at a charter school, and she succeeded there.
This is why I'm here to support Mariel Booker Leadership Academy because it's looking to support students to make sure that they can develop their own leadership.
Not just academically, but the necessary skills to lead a successful adult life.
That's why I'm here to support Mariel Booker Leadership Academy.
And if you're here to support Mariel Leadership Academy as well, can you please stand up?
Gracias.
Thank you.
With the following speakers, please line up at the podium.
Brian Greenberg, Patricia Chavez, Kimberly Evans, Geraldine Anderson, Juliesa Pineda, Robina Parker, Reverend Kism, Susan Fong, Tiana Coleman, Dwayne Gaines, Alan Choi, Vanessa Harlan, Janelle Rooley, and Ramel Antoine.
Hi, my name is Melissa Dar Carvajal.
I have two boys at Mission High School.
And I just have two points I want to make.
But I do want to reference this letter by Rachel Norton from the Board of Education.
She's a longtime board member.
I believe she was chair of the board.
So I draw your attention to that.
You know, it's really, I do communications and marketing professionally, and it's a very different skill to do communications and marketing and organizing than running a school.
My husband teaches, and I could never, ever do what he does every day at Mission High School.
So it's great that there is a lot of people here that they're organizing, but running a school is a whole different ballgame.
And that's what we're asking you to take a look at.
Secondly, at Willie Brown School, the school district has been putting lots of resources into it.
And now anybody goes to Willie Brown Middle School gets an automatic entry in Tier 3 into Lowell High School.
I don't know if you've heard about Lowell High School, but it's a very high demand, high academic high school.
And so with that, anyone who goes to Willie Brown is going to get into Lowell, and that's going to make it even harder to recruit the number of students that they say they're going to get.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Brian Greenberg.
I'm the CEO of the Silicon Schools Fund.
I'm also a career teacher, principal, and chief academic officer.
I've had the honor to speak to you before about some of the highest performing schools in the state that we've had the honor to work with.
Our portfolio now is 43 schools that we've helped to open or support, of which zero schools have closed, and of which now score at the 73rd percentile of our grade state in terms of student performance.
So our expertise is quality.
We have worked with the founder of this school, Terrence Davis, for more than three years at this point.
It's based on our expert opinion that we are extremely confident that this is the right team and that they are demonstrably likely to be highly successful.
Their founder, as you've seen, is a man of unusual character and academic preparation.
He's led within high-tech high, leadership public schools, schools that are emulated all across this country.
I spoke to his training principal recently, and he said to me he has the deep and dynamic approach to teaching and learning, combined with exceptional background in SPED, which is exactly what we need for leaders in our state.
This is the kind of school that parents in San Francisco deserve.
And when you look at the performance for African-American and Latino families currently, we need to give them options because currently only 6% of families in San Francisco have an option.
Thank you for focusing on quality.
Thank you.
My name is Kimberly Evans.
I have a master's in public health, and I am a doctoral student of cognition and instruction.
I am also a concerned community member, a volunteer, an activist, and a fierce village member for my nieces, nephews, and other children in the community.
I grew up in the Excelsior District and spent much time in Hunter's Point projects.
while attending elementary school in Bayview.
I'm supporting the Mary L. Booker Learning Academy because Bayview, Sunnydale, Visitation Valley, Excelsior, as well as others need Booker Academy so that children in low socioeconomic areas can enjoy the same educational advantages as those in upper echelon neighborhoods.
I believe that this school will not only allow children to have access and learning opportunities that are normally reserved for those in private schools and the likes such as artificial intelligence, dramatic arts, and other project-based learning concepts, but Booker Academy will also offer a safe and encouraging environment where students will be supported by volunteers
who have experience in mental health and other mentoring qualities.
This, I feel, will speak to those who suffer in tempered trauma with no resources.
The methodology of Booker Academy will prove to present fewer suspensions and more college-bound graduates.
We have a powerful potential in our youth, and we must have the courage to change old ideas and practices so that we may direct their power toward good ends.
Mary McLeod Bethune, activist and educator.
Thank you.
Hello, board members.
My name is Geraldine Anderson, a single working mother of three boys, two of who attended schools in the Bayview District of San Francisco.
I'm also the chairperson for Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy, as well as a chairperson for Innovate Public Schools.
I am here today in support of Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
Mary L. Booker was an amazing woman who had captured the Bayview with her generosity, with her time, positive influence, and continued service, especially in the arts, while teaching children, young adults, and elders to make the Bayview neighborhood a better place to live, work, and raise a family.
As a single mother, I look to the schools my children have attended to be a support system for my children and myself.
I ask that you take into deep consideration allowing this school to not only open, but stand to commemorate the values of Ms.
Booker bestowed on our neighborhood, especially our children.
I understand at this time our school district is in full throttle trying to make positive changes in our schools in the Bayview, but I would like to see additional choices and immediate remedies to the achievement gap that is currently active in our Bayview schools.
Our children and families deserve and need Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
Thank you, Commissioners.
Hello, everyone.
My name is Rovina Parker.
I'm a parent leader supporting Mary O. Booker Academy, I mean, schools in San Francisco.
I came all the way to Sacramento to speak to you today.
I hope that you will listen with your hearts.
I appreciate
The Frederick Douglass quote, it's easier to build strong children than to repair broken men.
To me, this means that a good school is essential for children's development.
Often we focus on having strong elementary schools, but we forget about middle school and our high school quality.
That's why I'm excited about the Mary L. Booker Academy, providing support, strong education, beginning with sixth grade.
Some of the things I'm most excited about with the school are new creative methods of teaching, such as project-based learning, strong teaching methods.
Strong teaching meets the kids where they are and will help them get to where they need to be.
We will most definitely, if you grant us, we will most definitely hold the school accountable.
Thank you for listening.
Hello, board.
My name is Dwayne Ganks.
I am from San Francisco.
I'm a native.
I came all the way here from San Francisco to support Mary Booker.
I work with Mary Booker as a stagehand at 17.
Like I said, I'm a graduate from Balboa High in 1983.
I was tested to a fifth grade level.
I went to Mr. Davis.
earlier this year and said, we need to have gun prevention in schools.
I got six degrees, San Quentin, Tracy.
I can name six prisons, and I ain't going to name them all right now.
But that's what I got from Samuelson School District.
We need to have a gun prevention.
I work with Ms.
London Breed and Gavin Newsom.
I told London office on Tuesday, the day of the week of the bad boy shooting, we need to have gun prevention.
I got a program.
We need to have gun preventions in schools, because it's the behavioral problems in the brown and black.
It's the behavioral problems, and we need to address them.
And San Francisco school districts are not addressing nothing.
Willie Brown School is sickening.
We need to do something about San Francisco school district, and you need to open Mary Booker School.
vote commissioners.
My name is Alan Choi.
I'm from San Francisco.
I find that equity part of the model that we have is something that is impartial without any preconceived idea of what to do for a kid who's supposedly to be expelled.
No, discipline comes with instruction and I feel that and I think that the capacity to learn
is given to each child.
I'm sure each one of you feels the same way about yourself.
So is this something that deems partiality?
No.
It deems intelligent.
It deems impartiality and also prayerful thought.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, commissioners.
My name is Tiana Coleman.
I'm here to recommend that you open the Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
Mary L. Booker was a pillar in the community.
She fought for the same injustices and inequalities in the 1950s as we fight for today.
As a community activist in the Bayview and in the southeast side of San Francisco, she worked as a teacher for the San Francisco Unified School District, dedicating her life to teaching and encouraging the youth and underserved members in that community.
She created theatrical programs within the Bayview Opera House in the Bayview area, working with neighboring communities and organizations to help enrich the lives of the community members.
As her niece and also as the board treasurer of the Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy, I stand here and with all of the supportive community members that we stand together to support Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
We believe that we represent the ideology that my aunt stood for.
Integrity, leadership, inclusion, equity, education, and enrichment of the community.
And as we vow to continue to work hard on implementing the core mission and providing an education for each and every child in the Bayview so that they can have a better opportunity in the future.
Thank you very much.
Good morning.
My name is Patricia Chavez and I'm here to support the Marielle Booker Leadership Academy because I want a school that will hold our kids accountable and hold them to a very high level.
I have a student in the district currently and we've been facing issues of bullying for the past four years.
I've spoken to teachers and the principal and the only recommendation I get from the principal is that if kids continue to bully him, he should fight back.
Eso me sorprende de un director.
Mi hijo muchas veces lo lleve al doctor por fuertes dolores estomacales que le daban, pero era puro estrés del miedo que sentía al ir a la escuela.
I couldn't believe that those are words coming from a principal.
I often had to take my son to the doctor because he had stomach pains, but the doctor said a lot of that was coming from stress pain that he was dealing because of these issues.
With the help of the doctor and the psychiatrist, which was then recommended for my son, we sent letters to the district and never heard back from anyone.
The teachers never supported my son.
Instead, they intimidated him.
Yo tengo papeles que puedo demostrar que estoy diciendo la verdad.
I have paperwork and documentation to show that all this is factual.
Me gustaría que le dieran la oportunidad a esta escuela de Mary Booker para que otros niños tengan un nivel académico alto y puedan ser escuchados y sean tratados como son, como niños.
I want this school, Mary Booker Leadership Academy, to be open because I want kids to succeed academically, but I also want them to be heard and feel like they can be kids.
Time.
Gracias.
Thank you.
Hola, buenos días.
Mi nombre es Julissa.
Good morning.
My name is Julissa.
Soy estudiante de high school.
I'm a high school student.
Y este día estamos exponiendo la necesidad de que apoye la Escuela Mary Booker.
And we're here today to show the need that we have for Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
Yo soy una estudiante que está aprendiendo inglés y como miles y miles de estudiantes que están aprendiendo inglés.
I'm a student learning English and like thousands and thousands of other students trying to learn English.
Una escuela pequeña nos brinda más ayuda que una escuela grande.
A small size school will be able to support us a lot better than a large school.
Somos jóvenes que venimos de otros países buscando una oportunidad de aprender y realizar nuestros sueños.
We're youth that might come from other countries, but we're all here in search of a dream, in search of a better future.
Desgraciadamente, las escuelas del distrito son muy grandes y muchas veces no tienen los recursos que necesitamos.
Unfortunately, most of the district schools are very large and don't offer us the support and resources that we need.
En cambio, Mary Booker será una escuela que nos va a incluir y dar los servicios y el respeto que merecemos.
On the other hand, Mariel Booker Leadership Academy is a school that will offer us the support and the resources to succeed.
Muchas gracias.
Thank you very much.
Hello, honorable commissioners.
My name is Susan Fong Wong.
I'm the parent of three SFUSD high school graduates.
I attended Houston, Texas public schools when they were still legally segregated by Jim Crow laws.
I grew up in the first ward of Houston, a predominantly African-American and Latino neighborhood.
I support the charter application of Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
This school is conceived of and supported by parents and community members of the Bayview, Excelsior and Mission neighborhoods of San Francisco.
I base my support for Mary L. Booker on the history of black education in the United States.
After the Civil War, the freed slave hungered for the education they were systematically denied on the plantation.
Northern churches funded schools for newly freed people.
Congress created the Freedmen's Bureau, which provided funding for new schools for black children.
In fact, ordinary black families took initiative to build schools for their children.
They purchased land, constructed buildings, and fundraised to hire teachers.
Howard, Fisk, Hampton were opened as black teachers colleges soon after the Civil War.
Within five years, these three colleges provided nearly 3,000 black teachers to educate the free people of the South.
Mariel Booker deserves your yes vote today.
You could change the lives of hundreds of students and their families when the school is rooted and committed to the community.
Thank you for your earnest consideration.
Thank you.
Good morning, Board President Kirsten, board members.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Many, and Core.
I'm excited to be here today in strong support of Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy.
Booker Academy will fill an important need in San Francisco with a unique educational program and a school model, a unique school model.
We seek your support.
Focusing on the charter petition, which really, after all, is the thing that we're here to talk about, I just wanted to remind the board of the default rule in the law to approve a charter petition unless we have written factual findings in one of six very narrow categories.
Charter schools really are intended as a yes and solution.
Approving a charter school doesn't take away anything from a school district.
This is just another option to help another set of kids with another choice.
Booker Academy is not going to take anything away from San Francisco Unified.
The charter school agrees to the two conditions from the CDE staff report and is more than willing to work on any changes necessary to address any remaining concerns.
Thank you very much.
Good morning board members, Deputy Superintendent Ramel Antoine on behalf of the Charter Schools Association.
We're proud to full heartedly ask the board to support the establishment of this school for the following reasons.
The petition meets the legal requirements.
The petitioner secured more than the necessary funding most recently passing peer review for the public charter school startup grant.
That's a significant step towards securing that money.
The academic program builds on the best practices from schools in our state and across the country, specifically working to target some of San Francisco's most underserved communities.
The leader, Terrence Davis, is incredibly prepared and resourced for this work.
He has shown himself to be committed to collaboration, community, and self-reflection in the service of kids and their families.
The Charter Schools Association asked the board move CD's recommendation and the ACCS's unanimous recommendation for support of this school.
Thank you.
Hola, muy buenos días.
Hoy en este día estoy muy contenta por estar aquí con ustedes.
Soy una mamá de tres hijos.
No tuve la oportunidad de ir a la escuela.
Siempre he trabajado para mantener a mi familia.
Good morning, everyone.
I'm very emotional and very excited to be here.
I'm a mother of three.
Myself, I never had the opportunity to go to schooling.
Le doy las gracias a ustedes por el gran apoyo que están dando, por su gran trabajo, y porque sé que ustedes van a apoyar a esta escuela, ya que esta escuela se enfoca en los niños latinos de la ciudad de San Francisco.
I want to thank you guys all for your support and your thoughtful consideration.
And I know you're here to support a school that's going to be looking out for the Latino students of San Francisco.
Habemos muchas personas latinas como yo que no tuvieron la oportunidad de leer, de escribir, que no sabemos usar una computadora, que no sabemos llenar un documento, que no sabemos hablar inglés.
Pero sé que gracias a esta escuela, los niños van a ser mejor que antes.
Gracias a todos ustedes por el apoyo.
thankful for the opportunity to support a school like Mariel Booker Leadership Academy, where myself, I didn't learn how to read.
I didn't learn how to write.
I don't know how to use a computer or how to fill out a document.
But because of schools like the Mariel Booker Leadership Academy, my children will have an opportunity to do so in the future.
Muchas gracias.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, everyone.
My name is Vanessa.
I am a San Francisco resident, born and raised.
I have four children.
My children did start off in the unified school district system.
Unfortunately, for all four, it didn't work for them, and they continued on into the charter-based system.
I'm a parent.
This is who I do it for.
And I want you guys to know that it's very, very important.
These kids' education is important.
And what I did was I went and opened up my own homeschool.
I figured it out because it just wasn't working.
So I support the charter school system.
I do, and what they're doing.
So I want you guys to know when you think hard and you think strong, think about these children right here.
What do we do it for?
One, two, three.
Thank you so much.
Morning commissioners.
That should sell it right there.
No, we laugh, but I'm serious.
This is not about bashing the San Francisco Unified School District.
Simply, they're just not getting the job done.
Millions of dollars are thrown at the system that is just not working.
What would you do if your children
We're failing.
They're getting good grades, but when they graduate, they can't compete because the A isn't an A, a B isn't a B. I'm not here to bash teachers that work extremely hard in a unified school district.
Would you look for a choice and would you look for a change?
The reasonable answer is yes, isn't it?
And that's all we're asking for today, is that you allow families like me, I'm a 50-year resident of San Francisco, raised five children in San Francisco, part of it in public school.
Had I not spent thousands of dollars to educate my children, they would not have graduated at grade level, at grade 12.
So I ask you today, please make the right choice, support Mary L. Booker School, and sleep well tonight.
God bless you.
That concludes the public comment?
Yes.
Okay.
So I think it's time to begin our discussion.
And so I'd like to call on our charter liaisons that follow this issue and attended the hearing of our, which I understand was over the phone, of our advisory committee on charter schools.
So which of you would like to lead?
I'll start.
Board member.
Williams.
There was only one charter appeal hearing at the last ACCS.
And so most of the advisory commission members did come here, including the chair, Brian Bauer.
A couple of them, Carolyn could address this more specifically if you have questions about that.
But a couple of them were on the, the others were on the phone.
Member Holiday and I watched the hearing from our homes as it was streamed live.
I was, I am incredibly impressed with this particular leader.
For one thing, I don't think we have enough African American male leaders for our schools and our students as role models.
But that's not why I was impressed with him.
I think he has a confidence and a sense of purpose and a sense of depth and a mission that really came through as we watched the hearing.
I think he's been supported to go through a considerable amount of training with mentors and
has worked in some of the best charter schools.
One of the things I want to point out is that he has chosen what he thinks is best from the charter schools he's been associated with.
He hasn't chosen the things he didn't like.
If those were discipline policies at certain charter schools, he's not bringing those things with him into this particular charter school and to Mariel Booker.
He's bringing the best of them and pulling them together.
He has a tremendous amount of support.
My understanding is that he does have 400 signatures and that there was a typographical error on some of the signature forms, but that the signatures are not duplicates, they're 400 actual.
I just found out today that if they pass to get a public charter school grant, that's a really strong indication that he would get that.
At the ACCS,
watching that and watching him and then watching the people that talked about it, then watching the deliberations.
You know, the ACCS, they don't always recommend approval of a charter school, and even when they do and have the majority, they often have a split vote.
I was most impressed
by Curtis's discussion with this petitioner at the meeting and his engagement with him, talking to him man-to-man about the importance of these students and what Terrence wants to do with them.
and intends to do with them.
And Curtis made, told him, told Terrence that he would like to support him.
He felt like he had everything it was going to take to pull this off, and it was an important cause.
And he wanted Terrence to promise that he would follow through and do everything that he says that he's going to do for these students.
and of course Terrence said yes.
So I will be ready to make a recommendation for approval of authorization for this school after the board has had a chance to talk.
Board member Holliday, do you wish to add anything at this point or?
I would like to add to what Member Williams said by saying that, once again, every charter item that comes before us seems to be increasingly contentious.
for one reason or another.
And in all these situations, we have to remember that this is not, whatever decision is made here, is not a judgment on the schools, the teachers, and the leadership of the district and the county.
Although in these conversations, you know, statistics are tossed around willy-nilly, we all know that what the district teachers and administrators are doing is the absolute best they can to serve their children.
What we are talking about here, though, is an opportunity
for a significant group of parents to have a choice.
And this choice seems to be a reasonable choice.
I agree with Member Williams that the leadership of this school is very impressive.
I'm particularly impressed with his willingness to meet with anyone in the community to talk about this school, to talk about his dreams, talk about the plans.
not just those who want to come to the school, but those who are opposed to the school.
He meets with them, he talks with them, and he tries to build a community relationship.
And I think that's remarkable for all sorts of reasons.
And the other thing is that this is not specifically a Bayview school.
This is a school, as you saw from his heat map and other documents that he showed, that will serve a broader section of, I guess you would say, Southeast San Francisco.
Once again, I know that the challenges of having a charter school co-locate with a traditional school.
But at the same time, that is a district decision.
How that will play out through Prop 39, that should not be a part of our decision.
I think all the pieces are right for this one.
I really do.
And if Member Williams makes a motion, I will support it.
OK.
Other board discussion?
Board Member Rucker.
Well, I had some questions for both the district and also for the charter school or manager.
Okay, I start with the district person, if he's still here.
Okay, so let me begin by saying I know that San Francisco School Board is not an anti-charter school board because you have approved charters before, is that correct?
Yes.
Okay, so I need to ask you to explain because I wasn't really clear in the presentation you gave about the reasons or the issues you have
about whether or not this charter petition shows a demonstrable ability to implement the program that's described.
Could you give me a little bit clearer explanation about what your findings were?
Because I heard a lot of mega terms and I saw a general description in your presentation, but I didn't really understand what your specific and explicit objection to the charter petition itself was.
So our review committee, and I explained, you know, that that is composed of a lot of people with a lot more expertise than I have.
We had problems as did the CDE staff with the description of pupil suspension.
We had issues with the description of the program and whether or not the program that was described also matched up with the abilities of the petitioners to actually carry out that program.
I'd have to go and get the actual document to give you the further details.
I'm sorry to say in general, but in general, our review found deficiencies in the petition as it was submitted now.
What tends to happen in this process is that petitions go to the local school district, they are found to be deficient, they come here, they are found to be deficient by the CDE staff, and then the petitioner is allowed to make changes to meet the conditions, and that is actually happening here.
So, look, I mean, we understand that
there's a lot of great intent on the part of the petitioner and that the default mold, as the petitioner's attorney said, you know, should be for the petition to go through unless certain findings are made.
Well, we firmly believe that we made the findings and we had our board adopt those findings for denial.
That doesn't mean that they can't make changes that will make it better, but what we're tasked with is looking at the petition as it's presented, and that's also what this body is tasked with.
And so, you know, it may sound
you know, unfair or overly restrictive to say, look, you need to present a petition, petitioner that meets the requirements of the law or else we will make the findings that you did not meet the requirements and you will be denied.
And we believe that once a local district has made that finding that it should be upheld here at the state level because then we have the situation where
The local district, for very valid reasons, has denied the petition, but then we, the local district, have the charter school operating within our jurisdiction, and we have no real means of monitoring what that charter school does with students that are coming from our school district.
They're not our students, but we have a responsibility because they reside within our boundaries.
Okay.
Thank you.
Lisa, could I ask you a question regarding the suspension issue?
And I understand what you said concerning the information on the suspension because of the change in the law that the petition itself had to be corrected to address those particular changes.
Could you explain that to us again?
Could you just explain that part to me?
Yes.
So there, the petitions, as even Mr. Davis stated, there were catching up, right?
So the petition is the same one that the district reviewed and the county reviewed.
So, their AB 1360 did go into effect in January.
So, we understand that some of these petitions are still catching up with the language and the intent of that law.
So, that's actually what we've stated is that as we see the petition, if it is authorized by the board, we do want to work with the petitioner to make those changes so that it's compliance with the law.
Okay.
All right.
So, then I do have a question for the charter school manager.
So I heard a lot of conversation, particularly from the Silicon Valley Association representative who talked about your expertise and your background for doing the work to lead this charter school.
So I'm going to I just want to ask you a couple of questions because what seems to be at issue and what seems to be central to this conversation is about the ability of the charter to implement the plan.
that you have described.
So I'm going to start with a question about restorative justice.
You've chosen to use that as the model for your discipline and intervention and support of students.
What other models did you consider?
Yes, absolutely.
It's a great question.
So the reason, so kind of taking a step back as to why going with restorative justice, and then I can get into the other ones that we considered.
For me, my background, and I haven't talked about it enough, was first as a special education teacher and then as an administrator.
The reason I've utilized a variety of different methods in terms of how we're supporting our students, what I have found with restorative justice is that it allows students to first and foremost stay in the classroom.
It allows us to solve dilemmas or problems and then be able to work together.
And so within that restorative, we were thinking of other models or other programs that we looked at.
I looked at just different schools and different approaches.
There's schools I've used and people have brought up, you know, demerits.
They've brought up, you know, different ways in which they've approached that.
What I've seen, not only is for us, the restorative justice is
central to our model, but we're utilizing the school Valor Collegiate.
So if you see in our packet, there's a letter from Valor Collegiate, which is a school that's using a compass model.
And so more so than just saying restorative justice, we also use a compass model, which is the full-fledged curriculum that we're using.
So to answer your question, I've worked at different schools where we've used demerits, discipline, all these different tactics.
I think what's been most successful is using the restorative justice model.
Okay, so I'm going to summarize what I heard you say.
You're familiar with a lot of different tactics for intervening on discipline issues, but the one specific model that you looked at or the only model that you actually looked at was restorative justice.
The only one that I consider for the school, yes.
Okay.
And what, in your background for special education, you said you were a special ed teacher.
Can you tell me about your assignment?
Yeah, absolutely.
So I've worked as a co-teacher.
I've worked as a case manager.
I've worked as a variety of different areas.
And one of the things I think that's not talked about enough as someone that's been in the special education field is that at a very early stage in my career, I was allowed from some of my school leaders to be put in a position to learn the different elements of leading a school.
So very early on in my career, I was put in a position of... Yeah, but I'm asking about your work as a special education teacher, not about your work in leading a school or your internship as a school.
So at High Tech High, my first job as a special education teacher, I was responsible for
monitoring students' progress, developing students' IEPs, pushing into classrooms, working with students who need to pull out of classrooms, communicating with parents.
When I worked at, when I moved on into Noble, I was a co-teacher and I also led classes and did self-contained classes.
Okay, so talk to me a little bit about the IEP work that you did.
Yes, I mean, at this point in my career, I've probably worked with over 1,000 IEPs in terms of meetings.
And so I've, again, been responsible for implementing their goals, making sure.
And one of the things I think that's unique with my experience is that because I have a special education background, we talk about a project-based learning school, a lot of times there's different modifications that are needed.
And so when I was working at High Tech High, I still had to make sure that we were honoring students' IEPs while at the same time implementing into a creative new environment.
So a good example is I would be responsible as a teacher.
I'd have a student who needed a textbook, right?
And I worked at a school where the classroom teacher wanted to use a project-based model.
And so I had to sit down with parent, teacher, and student to come to some type of solution so that it worked for everyone.
Because I think what's great, what's beneficial to my experience is being able to go in and see how you have these unique and innovative models, but then how do you make sure that it's built in a way for all students.
Okay.
In this state, well, all states, but in all states, there is a requirement that a report is submitted to the Office of Special Education Program
that enumerates and reviews all of the elements for compliance and compliance monitoring for special ed programs in districts.
Can you tell me about the OSEP report from the district and the schools that you'll be drawing students from?
What can you tell me about it?
I can't.
So I'd have to look at look at the numbers.
I can't tell it off the top of my head.
And what are you familiar with any of the issues on significant disproportionality that's existed in this particular district?
Yeah, so you're thinking of, so just to clarify your question, are you referring to specific subgroups of students with disabilities?
Yeah, so we've worked with the district, again, sorry, not worked with the district, we work with families and making sure that we're able to help serve.
So I want to kind of go back to our school model.
So when we're looking to develop a school model, the most important thing to me is that we're able to meet the needs of all students.
So I think what you're getting at is the variety of students that I've been able to support.
I've supported students that have been on the autism spectrum.
I supported a significant number of new students that have had
learning disabilities, behavioral disabilities, whatever, all the different categories we can look at.
And so for me, I feel very confident being able to support any student that comes through our school.
Okay, well, I don't think I asked the question correctly.
One of the areas that California in particular is out of compliance with according to the annual OSEP report that we submit and that we still have to develop a plan for addressing is the issue of significant disproportionality, meaning that students of color, particularly African-American students, particularly boys, tend to be referred more often
and in greater numbers out of proportion to what they represent in the population of students in the schools where they attend.
So my question to you, because this happens to be an issue in the district and in the areas that are identified that you plan to draw students from, what I asked you was, what in your plan and based on your special education background that you said is very deep,
and very broad, how in your plan are you planning to address this particular issue?
I didn't get an answer to that and I didn't mean to ask you a question to put you on the spot, but I want to understand if the issue is about whether or not you have implemented a plan
to that will address in appropriate ways and fully have success to implement the program.
You're going into a district where significant disproportionality is a significant issue.
There is no plan of correction in place for addressing this.
And you're going to be recruiting students from these schools to do this.
And there is no plan that addresses this work in the way that you're that in your program that I see.
Based on the expertise that you should have, I'm surprised that I did not see this address or particularly highlighted in your petition.
That's not something that needs to be revised here to satisfy me, but I am saying that that is a concern, that I have that concern about whether or not this work can be done going forward, particularly knowing
In this district, that's a concern.
Can I address that?
Go ahead.
Appreciate the clarification.
So, we go back to the core part of the school model.
What's most important is that we're creating elements so that every single student can be successful.
So, to your point, we're thinking about disproportionality.
and students are being labeled.
We have set aside time, our learning studio, for every single student, whether they have an IEP or not, so that every single student is getting that level of support.
We have personalized learning plans, which in reality will look very similar to an IEP because it's every student going at their own pace.
And so if we put those things in place, my belief is that it'll ensure that we aren't needing to recommend students because they're falling behind.
Similarly, if a student is having, you know, a lot of times it has to do with behavior and students being referred to for a behavioral reason,
We have elements where we can work with students in small groups, and that is for every single student that comes to our school.
We are starting with middle school, so it is a little different where, to your point, we're going to get some students who may or may not have already been qualified for an IEP.
But what I believe is that because we are focused on growing students in their reading and their writing and their math ability, we believe that our goal is to get them on track.
right, where our goal is to be able to support them in that area.
And so I think I agree.
I also point out that I'm very aware of, again, being a man of color and being in this leadership position and what it means to have conversations with our students and talking to them about what it means to make sure that you are going down the right path, going back to our dream team where we're bringing everyone together to make sure everyone knows
and that student's family, what they need to be successful, I think those are all elements that are going to lead to us being successful.
To your point of whether or not, you know, how we're, the percentage we'll have compared to the district, I think we'll figure that out when our school starts.
But I think the most important thing is that Mary L. Booker Leadership Academy will support every single student that goes through our doors.
I feel very confident that I've worked with the students from a variety of strengths, right, and a variety of areas where they needed support on.
And so I feel very confident that anyone that goes through our doors will be serviced.
Okay.
Thank you very much.
Member Burr is here and our lunches are there.
And so for the audience, we'll be coming and getting our lunches coming back and forth.
Go ahead, Sue.
Thank you.
I just actually wanted to build on a couple of comments that
board member Holliday made.
And I feel compelled to say this.
I have to say it about every other meeting, but charter schools are public schools.
We heard from a number of folks testifying, creating the dichotomy as if charters were some entity out here that are not part of the public school system.
And as Member Holiday said, it breaks my heart actually to see communities come up here sort of torn apart about these issues as if we're pitting one against the other.
That is not the intent, never been the intent for the 25 years that charters have been around.
They are there to provide a choice to parents, many of whom we heard here today,
and to school communities for a variety of options that will meet their students' needs.
So if I have to say at every meeting, I will, but please stop pitting charters and treating them as if they're not public schools because they are.
The other thing I want to say is that
We and I should let board member Williams say this because she says it a lot as well.
Our job is to conduct a fresh view of the charter petition.
And while I know and I really want to commend and appreciate what the district in this case because they operate as both the district and the county has done in conducting a very thorough review and came up with findings that they made as a recommendation to their board.
But when it comes to us it's
our staff's job, in this case, Lisa and her staff, to conduct a new review and to say, based on our review, here are our findings.
And we heard from Lisa.
You can look back at her presentation.
Her findings were slightly different than the district's and, in fact, found that they did meet the requirements of the charter law.
So I just wanted to clarify all of that.
And just to say that when the motion is made, I'm happy to support the school.
Board member Cardenas is next.
Okay, I'm sorry.
So my question goes back to board member Rucker.
It's about the restorative justice and what experience you have around that because one big concern is around expulsion and suspension.
And like in the packet, you gave all you said is that you want to work with it and improve it.
But I really want to understand the training and your background around restorative justice and have a deeper look because that does take a lot of years and takes a lot of hours.
And how are you planning to train your staff on restorative justice so that everybody's equipped with that?
Absolutely.
So, that's a great question.
So, first, going into my experience, the most recent school I worked at, Leadership Public Schools, we used the restorative practices.
From there, one of the things that I did, as I mentioned before, I went to a school in Nashville, Tennessee, which is Valor Collegiate.
I have some examples that I can provide the board, just so you can see some of the practices that we're using and the curriculum that I'm talking about.
What I think is unique about us adopting Valor Collegiate's compass model is that it's a full curriculum that we're looking at.
So students are working through ideas like identity, ideas like self-determination, all these areas where students are kind of developing their social emotional skills.
We're working and partnering with them.
The other part is that I think what makes it unique about our school is that we're providing 15 days of professional development before school starts, and ideas of restorative justice, trauma-informed training, culturally relevant pedagogy, all these areas that we're talking about, we have the capacity and time to make sure that our teachers are fully staffed and trained on this.
And so, I feel like I'm very confident in my ability to implement a restorative justice.
We've worked with the most successful programs in the country around this area, and then we will make sure that our teachers are trained in it.
And then my other question is around the enrollment process, because I saw that you have 120 spots and there's 400 interested families.
So how are you going to make sure you're able to equip, because that does mean you're going to have to turn down 280 families.
Yeah, that's an important question.
I think that's another part of thinking about how things work in San Francisco.
And so one of the things that, not too long ago, there was a letter written by the superintendent around parents trying to pick their schools.
And so again, we go back, and I appreciate some of the board members mentioning
every parent has the ability to choose which school they want to go to.
And so a lot of parents are doing that right now where they're making a decision as to where am I going to send my student.
And so we, what I've been telling every parent is that we want to be one of those options.
So the technical point is we will have a lottery.
Our lottery prioritizes students that are free and reduced lunch and then also come from the communities we hope to serve.
To your point, when you have a big group of students that want to go to the school, there will be some that may not be able to get in.
But I also think that the reason we try to recruit so many is that we also know that parents may end up getting another option.
And so we want to make sure that we're providing it to as many students as possible.
So, will it change depending on the outcomes of Prop 39 if you are approved?
No.
So, it will not change.
And the other thing is that we, so another point that's important because we don't know where our location is, and that's a Mr. Davis, the other Mr. Davis decision.
We recruited from multiple neighborhoods, so three different neighborhoods.
So, when you look at that 400 to your point,
In theory, if we get placed in an area that is way far away, parents may choose that they want to go to school a little closer, they may make their decision, which is more reason for us to recruit a high number.
And even that number we have, we're still trying to get more because we know that as student parents are making that decision, a lot of it will be around the school model, but a part of it is going to be, do you have access to that?
And that's one thing because we can't guarantee that right now with the Prop 39 process, we're trying to recruit as many students as possible.
OK, Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
I just have a general comment.
No, no, no question.
Thank you.
You know, I think who the leader of a school is critical.
Leadership is critical because this is a new school.
It's in a very vulnerable community in terms of the students that you're hoping to reach.
We've had several petitioners that have come before the board and I myself have been very concerned about their limited experience.
We've had somebody that was approved with two years of teaching experience.
My, I think it matters, but if we're going to make it an issue that should matter for us, then we should be very standard in that concern.
I have an issue with selecting to question this petitioner when we haven't done this in-depth, background, professional query from others.
You know, for me, when I read the materials from San Francisco Unified, that seemed to be the one issue they had, really questioning, what is your background?
What is your experience?
And again, it matters, but if it's going to matter to that degree, then let's make sure we vet every single one of the leaders.
I have an issue when we happen to up the scrutiny when it's a person of color.
So that is just my personal.
My personal of the day, when it comes to both sides of, you know, the fierce village member, somebody said that, and I love that quote, a fierce village member.
I think there's on both sides, we see that, right?
And you're all right.
The public school system worked for me from elementary to my doctorate.
It's working for my children who are in district schools.
My choice is to put my kids in a district school, but that's not the choice I can impose upon everyone else.
And I believe San Francisco Unified is doing an amazing job for the students that it's serving well.
But that doesn't mean that it is the only choice that parents should have.
When it comes to this particular petitioner and the charter, one of the big differences that I see between the national CMOs that come into a community, always a community of color, always a low-income community, and kind of parachute in,
is that instead of just coming in, you're really seeking to grow from the members that are already in that community.
And I appreciate that because I think that's a very different model when you're trying to grow the movement and the foundation with those that are part of that community, even though you may not be from that community.
And I know I'm I'm from Long Beach and I'm Long Beach 1975.
And if you're not 1975 or 80, I'm like, how long have you been in my community?
Right.
So I get it.
I get it.
But I also get that.
When our heart and our passion is in the right place, we seek to build communities wherever we go.
So I also support this charter petition.
Ting Sun.
Board Member Sun.
Thank you.
So I was, many of my colleagues have already expressed a lot of what I'm feeling.
It is heart-wrenching to hear board meeting after board meeting, the communities coming up here and just at each other.
And it is not what the intent of chartering was to be about in this state.
And I do appreciate Board Member Burr bringing up, again, charter schools are public schools and our process for review of a charter is a de novo review.
That all said, I also consider the need for a charter school.
I also look at
Is it a charter school that's been dropped into the community because it was some kind of a strategic plan by some organization outside of the community?
Or if it is actually something that is building within the community and there's a strong need?
There were a couple of schools that was mentioned in some of the letters from the stakeholders here.
that talked about some of the improvements that San Francisco schools are making, and I think that's fantastic.
Malcolm X Academy was one of the schools, and I see from our dashboard that there is great improvement in that school.
It is a K-5 school from my understanding, and our petition here is for middle and then eventually high school.
When I look at another school that was mentioned here,
the Willie Brown Jr.
Middle School, and I look at the dashboard results for that, our latest dashboard results for that, clearly, clearly there is a need in the middle school area grade levels to serve our subgroups and serve our students who are socioeconomically disadvantaged.
So, in looking at all of this in whole, the quality of the petitioner's petition, the quality of the petitioners, and also the need, I am in full support of this petition.
Karen Valdez.
I had a question for Mr. Davis.
This Mr. Davis, right?
Sorry.
Could you just clarify which SELP are you going to be working with?
We'll work with Eldorado.
Eldorado?
Yep.
OK.
And then are you- Sorry, let me say, our intention is to work with Eldorado.
And then in terms of due process, because I get the restorative practice or justice component, and that as an alternative to suspension, you're probably going to be looking at other means of correction probably.
But within the due process, what are your plans and what are the deficits that you need to shore up?
Yeah, so just to clarify with the CDE staff, it had to do with a timeline, and so that is the part that we've agreed with adjusting it.
I don't think that changes anything in terms of our school model.
And so going back to I think what's been talked about, just to clarify,
The city staff, and again, I've spoken with them over the phone plenty of times.
I see exactly where they pointed out.
We're going to comply with it.
And so our timeline will align with what the city staff's recommendation.
And that due process, that doesn't change anything about our school model.
It doesn't make it any different.
Again, I'll go back to my experience as a special education teacher.
I was in charge of manifestation hearings.
I have a clear understanding what it means to make sure students have due process.
I'll point out our dream team, again, where we're trying to make sure we're partnering with families early so we don't get to this point.
never know if we have to get down there, but we're going to try to be as preventative as possible.
Okay.
And I want you to know I am impressed by your skill set.
I appreciate your communication skills, the way you've reached out to community.
And in addition to that, I am very impressed by 15 days before school starts, you'll be working with your staff.
Is that part, that's part of your school calendar?
I've got, so I've got a bucket of papers.
I don't want to overwhelm you guys, but if you're curious to see our professional development calendar, I can,
I wasn't sure if you guys wanted to see all that, but we have a calendar.
And again, part of that reason is that every successful school that I've worked at has had three weeks of professional development before you go into the school.
I don't know what it looks like being at a school where we don't have that level of professional development.
If we're going to talk about having strong restorative justice practices, we've got to make sure we're giving time for our teachers.
We have that built in 15 days before, and we also would do it throughout the year, 24 days, including the 15, throughout the school year.
So nine additional days throughout the school year.
Okay.
Thank you.
Board Member Strauss.
So first I want to thank everyone who came from San Francisco to spend their time with us and to share their opinions and your commitment.
What I hear everybody saying is that we really want good schools for our kids and I just want to thank you all for coming.
I do have a question for Lisa to be really clear for us and
maybe clarify for everyone here.
The law is very clear as to what our role is at this point.
And so member Burr did say we have to do a full neutral new hearing and a new review.
Would you clarify for us under the terms what our responsibility is, what the law requires the board to do and under what guidelines we make the decision to approve or disapprove this charter?
It would just be helpful.
Okay, so
I can read directly from the Ed Code.
Is that more of what you're looking for, kind of what is before you, basically?
Okay.
So the Ed Code section 47605 states that the governing board of a school district, in this case the state board,
shall not deny a petition for the establishment of a charter school unless it makes written factual findings specific to the particular petition setting forth specific facts to support one or more of the following findings.
So the first is that the charter school presents an unsound educational program for the pupils to be enrolled in the charter school.
Number two is the petitioners are demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition.
The petition does not contain the number of signatures required by the subdivision.
The petition does not contain an affirmation of each of the conditions described in subdivision D. And the petition does not contain reasonably comprehensive description of all of the 16 charter elements.
So, when I presented this item before you today, our recommendation is based on the findings.
So, we found that they had a sound educational program.
We found that they were demonstrably, I always get caught up on that word,
likely to successfully implement the program and that we felt that most of the charter elements, there was a reasonably comprehensive description of most of the charter elements.
And then I did describe in the presentation the ones we felt we did need to work with the petitioner on if it was approved by the state board.
So that's why we lay out the findings the way we do.
And it's my understanding that there's been a thorough review at ACCS as well, and they found 9-0 to support the recommendation.
That's correct.
Thank you.
Okay.
And are we ready for a motion or Board Member Williams?
Based upon the recommendation of the CDE for the State Board to authorize Mary L. Booker and based upon the unanimous recommendation of the ACCS to do the same, I move the CDE's recommendation for the State Board to authorize Mary L. Booker Charter School.
Second by member Holliday.
Okay, I guess we have a clerk call the roll.
These have been
Okay.
Sue Burr.
Aye.
Emma Cardenas.
Bruce Holladay.
Aye.
Mike Kirst.
Lisa Ortiz-Licone.
Aye.
Patricia Rucker.
Nikki Sandoval.
Aye.
Eileen Strauss.
Ting Sun.
Aye.
Karen Valdez.
Trish Williams.
Aye.
Unanimous.
Thank you.
The petition is approved.
So I think we'll take a brief recess till maybe 12, 1230 to get our lunch and come back.
Yeah.
There's a lunch break till 1230.
Okay, the State Board will reconvene and we're now on item 20, State Board priorities.
And so I need a two, we have two approvals we need to make.
One is on the minutes.
Do I have a motion on the minutes?
You can use my mic.
Okay.
And so, all those in favor of approving our minutes, raise your hand.
Those are approved.
Then we have the second, which is the screening committee recommendation for appointments to the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools, the CPAG group, and the Instructional Quality Group.
and the ACCS.
So this is the time of year when we try to fill up all of our advisory committees.
And I'm going to go through each of these just so that we make sure we understand who's serving for what.
And first, I just want to thank the people who helped me.
My colleague Feliza Ortiz-Lincon helped with the screening and the interviewing for CPEG.
and for the IQC, as well as the student recommendations you heard yesterday.
And Trish Williams assisted me with the ACCS, as well as our staff, Carolyn Pfister, Amy Babico, Patricia Dacoste, Pam Kasselman.
We couldn't do this without all these folks.
So let me just say with respect first to the IQC, and I should say you have this on your addendum.
So I'm just going to say this for people who maybe have not seen the addendum yet.
The IQC, we began the recruitment in August.
We had many, many qualified applicants, over 60 applicants, who applied to be on the Instructional Quality Commission.
And the folks that we are recommending move forward are Manuel Rustin,
He's a teacher in Pasadena Unified School District.
His area of expertise is history, social science.
David Panthai, a teacher in Sacramento City Unified School District.
His expertise is English language arts.
Pamela Williamson, a teacher in Fairfield Sassoon District.
She's also an expert in history, social science.
And we're recommending an appointment for 2020
of Christina Andre, who's a teacher in the Ontario Montclair School District.
She's an elementary teacher.
She has lots of expertise, ELA, ELD, history, social science, math, and science.
With respect, and we're going to do all these in one fell swoop, the California Practitioners Advisory Group
We were recruiting for specific categories, charter school leaders, principals, and other school leaders, teachers from traditional public schools and charter schools, and career and technical educators.
We had three vacancies.
We're recommending that the following three individuals be...
appointed to fill those terms.
Janelle Woodward, she's a senior leadership associate with the Riverside County Office of Education.
She would represent principals and other school leaders for a three-year term beginning January 2019.
Diane Grotjohn, who's the accountability administrator with the Lifelong Learning Administration Corporation.
She'll represent charter school leaders for the same three-year term.
and Bootsie Battle-Holt, who's a teacher in the LA Unified School District.
She would also serve a three-year term for that same period of time.
I love her name.
I know it's the best name ever.
Then we're recommending the reappointment of four members on CPAG.
Jorge Aguilar, who's the superintendent of Sacramento City Unified.
Kimberly Kinney, I think it is, who's a school board member with the Pasadena Unified School District.
Linda Kaminski, superintendent of the Azusa Unified School District.
Tara Kinney, who's a senior policy advisor with the Learning Policy Institute.
And Mariana Astorga-Almanza, who's the visual and performing arts coordinator in Linwood School District.
So that's CPAG.
The last group is the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
We're recommending the appointment of a teacher representative, Terry Jackson.
She's a teacher in the West Contra Costa Unified School District for a two-year term starting January 19th.
And we will be reopening the recruitment for in ACCS
for a replacement for a representative of a charter school to replace Brian Bauer.
So that will be re-advertising for that beginning next Monday.
And then we'll do the screening and the interviewing in mid-December.
And we'll be back with you in January for that one appointment.
So with that, again, thank you to everybody that helped out on that.
I recommend approval of the recommendation for the appointments as outlined.
Second by Board Member Sun.
All right.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
That's approved.
Okay.
We're now down to our reports and we do this alphabetically on whatever you want to talk about.
So, on your activities.
So, Member Burr, you're back on.
I'm done.
You heard about CCE yesterday directly from Tom Armolino, which I really appreciated.
That was very informative.
We are next meeting is the first Thursday of December, which I think is the sixth off the top of my head.
out at the Sacramento County Office of Education.
I'll just add, Tom didn't talk so much about this yesterday, but we have a really robust communications plan that we'll be talking about at that meeting.
We've redone our website.
And so folks who are interested in staying up to date on CCEE, there's lots of ways to do that.
Check out the website and follow us on Twitter.
Okay, good.
Board member Cardenas.
Thank you.
So it's on the California Association of Student Councils and the Student Advisory Board on Education.
It was a very successful conference, as you saw.
The students came up with five proposals.
And just to say, these were only five proposals, and they had to choose from more than 50 topics.
within two hours, and so just know that there's a lot more energy for other different types of topics that these students will be working on, and that we appreciate the advice that you all gave.
We will be following up with everybody on the IQC, how we really want a student representative on the IQC in trying to build that connection, and we appreciate talking about the public comment and how the different frameworks and standards have that public comment open.
So I'm going to start thinking about how to build a campaign to spread awareness on that to, you know, get more student voice around that.
And just to know that this conference was not only about building proposals, but training students.
They got trained on school site councils, LCAP, LCFF, and they also were taught on how to implement these proposals on a local level.
to find out that, you know, only because we presented to the California State Board, this work continues no matter what.
And so I'm looking forward to hearing updates from the students.
And the students will also be looking at how to get more student board members on their local districts and, you know, how to build that advocacy so that there's more student board members in California.
So, like I said, thank you very much for hearing the students.
We truly appreciate it.
And yes, that's all.
Okay, I'm next.
I went to a conference called Just Equations at the University of California at Berkeley, sponsored by the Opportunity Institute there, which is part of Berkeley.
It was very interesting.
I urge you to read the EdSource report today on Cal State changing its math requirements and remediation requirements.
The community colleges were there, the UC.
I was on a panel.
The tectonic plates are moving in higher education in terms of what mathematics they consider that you need to know and be able to do to succeed there.
It's much more directed by pathways in the future.
You're going into the social sciences or the humanities.
take more courses in statistics and quantitative reasoning.
If you're going into STEM, of course, you're going through the traditional Algebra II.
The stranglehold of the mathematics departments in defining what ought to be math in terms of what you need for college seems to be eroding in both institutions.
I don't know about Berkeley.
So there's a lot of movement here and we need to observe it and
And there's strong implications for us as they communicate different signals about what mathematics is most worth knowing for which types of students down the line.
So it was very interesting.
And I, of course, raised all the issues of who's producing these teachers for these new courses, for the computer science courses, which may also, which will also be part of this.
And how are we to get the capacity
to do all this.
And I met for several hours with a delegation from Cal State U on their requirement to have a fourth year of mathematics required for all their entrants.
That way, 75% of their students now do have four years, but they
That's again an issue for us and how to engineer that.
We had a very productive discussion.
So this is a discussion of board priorities and what I emerged with yesterday's Discover.
I'm still on the mathematics theme.
I was very informed by board member Rucker's comments on the shortcomings of where of, you know, our past history in mathematics.
Karen Valdez, you know, added today that a lot of that's significant.
Some districts went, integrated math, then decided to go back to traditional and leave it all to their, mostly all of their teachers.
And so we've had this movement between integrated, the integrated math and the K-8.
It sometimes doesn't tie in with the high schools and they're shifting.
Our materials are outdated, but I thought what board member Rucker was saying was, you know, we just don't have a vision, a clear idea of what this ought to look like operationally and what students ought to know and how teachers can proceed.
So, I would think the board ought to work with the department and, you know, see if there's a strategy rethink we need.
Board member Strauss is going to a two-day meeting of the California Collaborative in Long Beach.
And we probably want a caucus before that to talk about that in that area.
So, I think, you know, a priority ought to be more on where we are in mathematics and where we need to go.
And that would be my recommendation.
And that we confer with the department.
Okay, Ortiz-Lacombe.
No.
Our alphabetizing isn't exactly accurate.
Oh, there you are.
Bruce Holliday.
I'm going from the script.
And you know, all right, go ahead.
Member Berg just mentioned briefly about needing to replace Brian Bauer on the ACCS.
It's public knowledge.
The mic's on for some reason.
Member Burr mentioned needing to replace Brian Bauer on the ACCS.
For those of you who have not ever taken time to watch an ACCS meeting or be a part of it, there's a lot of very good people on the ACCS who take a great deal of time and energy.
to read the petitions, to think about them, to research, and to make really sincere recommendations.
I'd like to make a shout out to Curtis Washington, who has served for many years on the ACCS representing teachers.
And he has done a tremendous job.
For the ACCS and for us Excuse me, but I really have to have a super shout out for Brian Bauer who has been chair for 10 years I believe or more he runs a really tight meeting
Which I appreciate.
He's fair.
He's considerate.
He makes sure that every person is heard.
And he just does a terrific job.
And I just wanted to make sure that all of you were aware of the great work that Brian has done over the years.
And I know that we will miss him in that role.
But my other task is to tell you a little bit about the Environmental Literacy Initiative.
The Environmental Literacy Initiative is working with the California Subject Matter Project to integrate environmental literacy into all of the various teaching programs.
They're also working with the California Science Teachers Association currently to focus the 2018 conference on climate change education.
And hopefully the result will be that thousands of California teachers will receive training and resources for teaching about climate change.
Since we last met Senate bill 720 authored by Senator about Ben Allen and co-authored by Assemblymember Tony Thurmond and sponsored by 10 strands Was signed by the governor did pass and was signed by the governor and what it does is it codifies?
California's commitment to ensuring that all public school students have the opportunity to become environmentally literate and also at the end of September the environmental literacy initiative held
an environmental literacy event at the Global Climate Action Summit in San Francisco.
More than 160 leaders in business, government, and education from around the globe participated in the affiliate event, including a number of state board members.
It focused on climate education being fundamental to advancing climate action.
And that's it.
Thank you.
Now, Ortiz-Lacombe.
I mentioned the health framework yesterday a couple of times, but over 200 edits were made to the health education framework based on the first 60 days of public comment.
We're moving to a second round of public comment for another 60 days.
And the public could access the framework in cde.ca.gov.
Again, it'll be out for public comment starting now until January of 2019.
And I think definitely right on, encourage the students to continue looking.
We do have the Ethnic Studies Framework that we'll start on rolling out, well, we'll start creating it, we have nothing, but I think that's a framework that would be of interest to our youth.
The other thing that I did on behalf of the State Board, I presented at the Groundmakers Conference entitled The Equity Journey, Investing in the Whole Learner, regarding the EO roadmap.
So I presented with Dr. Lori Olson, the Sobrato Family Foundation, and Californians Together.
There is a great deal of interest not only from California, but from other states to replicate the eel roadmap.
So I think we have a sample policy there.
Congratulations to all of us for that.
Thank you.
Okay, board member Rucker.
Okay, so this week I attended a meeting of the California State Council.
This is the council that does and monitors California's engagement and implementation of the Interstate Compact on educational opportunity for military children.
California has a lot of children who are military dependents enrolled in our public schools.
across the state.
I'm happy to report that for the first time since I have been on the council, we now have a state council in all 50 states.
What it does is help us to create unified programs and policies for transfer and movement of military students both in and around our schools in state and when they come from out of state and interestingly from other countries as well.
The compact, the council is planning a training coming up in the 2019-20 school year.
There will be a training in the north and the south.
We're looking at taking some concerted actions on creating a website for posting information on the activities of the council and to explain the elements and the policy that's covered under federal law in the interstate compact.
We're looking at creating a Purple Star program to recognize schools that have significant populations of military students and dependents to recognize their support in the work that they're doing.
There's also some work being done to document and take care of how we monitor
and do intake on concerns and complaints looking at a case study process and how to aggregate or keep that in some type of collection.
There was a couple of advisories that have come out concerning Tdap and the immunization requirement.
There's a difference in both federal law and our California policy on immunizations.
But under the federal law,
The students who are military dependents who transfer in or enroll in schools in California have 30 days from the date of enrollment to get the Tdap immunization done so that it doesn't stop them from being able to immediately attend school.
Whereas in California, students have to have that immunization as a prior condition of beginning to attend school.
And this is a case where the compact itself supersedes state law.
And so that's some information we're trying to figure out how to get out to the schools and inform our superintendents.
Next week, I'll be attending or participating on behalf of the board on a CDE work group on significant disproportionality, a statewide stakeholder meeting.
Ever since Fred started making those reports for the OSEP document,
to this board I have always been monitoring and had a concern about the issues of significant disproportionality primarily because we remain out of compliance from year to year and we were out of compliance even when I was a classroom teacher and it seems to be almost an intractable issue.
There's a lot of work being done at this particular meeting next week on November 16th.
The meeting outcomes include creating a strategy for monitoring LEAs that are reporting significant disproportionality
developing a comprehensive letter of notification, producing an outline for a white paper to highlight and update the progress toward addressing it, as well as start the discussion on how to most effectively incorporate the monitoring of preschools and schools that have low enrollment like charters.
And then next month, and I just closed for some reason that I noticed, next month I received an invitation from the department to sit in on a panel at the, I got to open this email again to make sure I have it correct.
The California Department English Learner Support Division is having their 19th Annual Accountability Leadership Institute on December 3rd and 4th at the Westin St.
Francis.
There's going to be a panel on December 4th called the English Learner Roadmap
leading through a system of support.
This will be a panel discussion talking about the legacy of Tom Torlakson as the superintendent of public instruction and creating policy to support the development and school improvement needs to address the support of English learners.
So the focus of this year's institute is on the roadmap and its principles and the elements for the paradigm shift that it creates in doing the work we have to do to address the needs of English learners.
I talked to you about what I did this week, what I'm looking forward to next week and next month.
It's going to be a busy couple of months for me before the next board meeting.
Okay.
Board member Sandoval.
Right.
The Advisory Commission on Special Education met on October 24th and 25th, and Shiloh Duncan-Vesterill of the Special Education Division presented information from the state's annual performance report, which we can look forward to seeing at the January meeting.
And she also identified the three priorities for the division, which is preschool inclusion, mapping to employment, reading literacy, and communicative competence.
And just a few quick reminders.
11.2% of students in California are students with disabilities.
And 71% of students, unduplicated, students with disabilities are part of one or more of the LCFF groups.
And one area to pay close attention to is disproportionality, which Member Rucker had mentioned, continues to... There are stakeholder groups that are meeting, and next week is the next one.
So we'll learn more about that.
There's still much work to be done in that area.
And one area to highlight is post-secondary outcomes for students with disabilities.
Three targets were met, and more students with IEPs enrolled in post-secondary school or became competitively employed, or both, within one year of leaving high school.
So that's something that is improving.
And for the California State Summer School for the Arts, Dr. David Harrington of UC Santa Cruz has prepared an evaluation of student perceptions of the school annually for the past 32 years that the school's been in operation.
And there are very high response rates on this evaluation.
In this last year, out of the 492 graduates, 88% responded to the survey, and 90% of those students described the overall program as either excellent or very good, so highly rated.
And Student Voices affirmed that California State Summer School for the Arts has, again, provided valuable and enthusiastically received opportunities for artistic and personal growth.
And one thing I'd like to highlight is the Herb Alpert Foundation contributed $340,000 to fund 21 scholarships for students this year, and the awards range from $2,500 to $40,000.
So it's helping our graduates of the California State Summer School for the Arts go into college and help meet those financial gaps.
So, thank you.
All right, Board Member Sun.
All right.
So the California Advisory Workforce Pathways Advisory Joint Committee is meeting on the 26th later this month.
And so we did present on the principles that we have developed
for moving forward and creating quality CTE pathways.
And our next step is to work and in collaboration with CDE and the community college system on the strong workforce grant that will be coming out and also on the continuation of CTEG.
And part of the work is looking at metrics and the metrics that will be coming out of these two grant programs and aligning those metrics so that we do have more of a cohesive, comprehensive system for continuing students from K-12 into the community college pathways.
when they, as they matriculate.
So there's a lot more work ahead.
And then also with the reauthorization of Perkins, that is another big piece of work that this committee will be taking on in 2019.
And then,
If I could also, since everyone's feeling nostalgic, and this is Tom's last meeting with us too, and it's something that as Carrick had come up and talked a little bit about how much the system of assessment accountability has grown.
And I cannot think of a more apt visual as I have known Carrick for a very, very long time, almost 25 years now.
And the visual I always have is of Carrick in his cubicle in the old school fiscal services division where, what was the system before CALPADS?
Was it CSIS or?
Yes, it was CSIS.
where he alone in his cubicle was the thesis guy.
And in dealing with some charter school issues, I always had to go over to Carrick's cubicle and ask him questions about things.
So now this is a full-fledged division.
And I just want to commend Carrick and the work and with support of Tom over these last few years.
I've also been a fan of the, quote, North-South meetings.
And I've lived through, I've gone through the whole API system and the old accountability system and development of that.
and now merging into the new one.
And I am just so impressed with the work of Carrick's team, Michelle Center, Cindy Kazanas, Jenny Sink, and how cohesive this system has been built.
And so I appreciate that.
I also appreciate the work that they do in reaching out to stakeholders.
We hear a lot of
the policy issues as staff presents it to us, they flip it around and they tweak it so that it is very understandable to the practitioners, the administrators, the teachers who are out there in the field.
And that's greatly, greatly appreciated.
So I wanted to do a shout out to Carrick and his team and the work that the department has done in both our data systems, our assessment, and our accountability.
Okay, great.
Board member Valdez.
You did forget Strauss.
It's OK.
Go ahead, Karen.
Eileen is next.
Board member Strauss.
Yeah.
Last board meeting, I left quickly because I was going to be having a grandson.
So my grandson is now six weeks old.
So I am proud to announce David Paul.
I joined the CPEG meeting virtually.
It was the first time they've done a virtual meeting, if you will.
And it was a diverse group.
I think it's really great to hear the new members and the current members being approved.
I think that that's just, they contribute so much.
And so it's just great to see that they'll be continuing.
I'm going to attend the November IQC meeting next week for the portion of the world languages as they'll be looking at the world language standards and the committee members.
There's 62 applications.
And I finally am going to be asked to be a keynote at the accountability for English learners next week or in December.
And it's with a focus on the roadmap.
So I'm excited to be able to do that.
Now Board Member Strauss.
Thank you.
I have a few things.
So just a shout out actually to Glenn Price and his work.
On the 12th of October, the Social Emotional Learning Group met, which has been something I think close to a lot of our hearts.
And we're part of a national consortium that's working on it.
And so there's some standards now that they've worked really hard on.
There's some resources posted on the CD website.
And I just think they're doing really good work to try to show how that relates to a lot of our work.
The Credentialing Commission met on the 27th of September.
I just want to highlight a couple things related, showing the coherence across the work of credentialing and our work.
So for the administrators, they now have a performance assessment like teachers have in three areas, analyzing data to inform school improvement and promote equity, facilitating communities of practice, which is what we've been hearing about,
and supporting teacher growth.
And so as part of their credentialing program, they have to do these performance assessments.
And it's threaded in their coursework.
CTC talked a lot about the teacher shortage challenge, which we know is a really big issue, and grants to recruit teachers.
They're looking at alternative routes and intern credentials, both through district-sponsored ones and university-sponsored programs, and they hear a lot about district-sponsoring credential programs.
We heard, actually, the high-tech, I've actually seen their credentialing programs, really impressive.
And then they have a CTE work group to look at a work group to strengthen the viability of CTE programs Which is really important as we look at college and career readiness So I think that'll be interesting to see kind of what they come up with as well So I will actually join on Thursday night and Friday for CTE for C. I am IQC we're going to be recognizing four members who are going off after their service member record I'll be doing that and
And then they are not only selecting recommendations for framework teams on world language, but also VAPA also.
So even though we think there's not much more we could, we still have a few more frameworks we need to update.
And so we are very fortunate to have a lot of applicants.
The core advisory council, they meet periodically to look at the core districts and what they're doing, and look at their data collaborative.
Some other districts besides core districts now have joined that, and they met a few weeks ago.
And pretty interesting to see the coherence around root cause analysis, what the role of counselors are, how do we look at coherence and implementation, what's the messaging to our communities, and how do we move systems forward.
So really across all of our work,
They have, and then they talked a lot about growth measures and why growth matters, which I know we're still really looking at.
They have a really exciting new project and funded, I think, through some of the Gates money called Freshmen on Track.
And looking at the freshman journey and what data, those of us who lived in high schools know it's a long journey from freshman year to high school graduation.
So looking at indicators and what roles counselors play, course preparation, bridges in the summer.
I think that work will actually really help inform our statewide commitment to the equity
completion at a high level.
There was, as you know, there was a STEAM conference, and then connected to that, the California for NGSS met at the CSU Chancellor's Office last week.
So a lot of the things that we saw yesterday on science, all the pieces are connected about how we're continuing to roll it out.
And CTA did a great presentation on actual science standards and what the practices are.
And then they had a panel on district implementation, Oakland, San Lorenzo, Tracy, and Val Verde.
And so I think those things that we're talking about from science and how to implement going forward, those will help advise, I think, and looking at high-quality instructional materials, which we did, assessments, learning opportunities for teachers, and capacity for teacher leaders, principals, and district leaders.
So we're seeing themes across all of our work.
And so at least in our roles, we'll try to connect.
Next week,
There's a meeting at CSU Chancellor's Office.
I'm getting real good at that parking at the Catalina Landing there.
But anyway, they're going to be looking, following up on what Board President Kearse is talking about, their Advisory Board on Quantitative Reasoning Task Force Report.
And what are the most pressing issues around mathematics?
How do we work collectively to address them?
What are the projects in CSU that are looking at mathematics?
Are we doing things right?
Where are we going?
How do we get there?
I think the exciting thing is it's a K-12 through higher ed discussion.
And I'll be glad to bring back what the conversation is.
It comes from the credentialing commission work.
And then following up on what member Holiday said about environmental literacy.
There's a big desire to do an environmental literacy climate summit next fall.
And that's a collaboration between K-12 and UCCSU.
And so we had a planning meeting, the department of ed was there, we were there.
Trying to decide how to look at that how to highlight it ten strands plays an important role in that our california teachers science teacher association And so they're talking about fall of 2019 have at a summit around um sustainability and climate So again, that's woven through the steam conference.
It's woven through the science teacher association conference, but they want a separate spotlight So as we work it through we'll bring you up to date on how those pieces will connect Thank you very much board member williams
I attended and participated at the end of September in Denver at a Code.org plus the National Computer Science Teachers Association States Policy Forum.
I was asked to present a session on how to engage state board members around computer science.
they thought I might be particularly qualified for addressing that.
But as it turned out, I actually had to do some real thinking about it because I realized when I started looking up on NASB, how many state board members are elected versus appointed and what kind of a difference that makes in terms of how they perceive their role, their job, and whether or not the superintendent is appointed by the board or elected.
in a general election and all that changes the dynamics on how you might approach state board members.
Even so, it was an interesting learning experience for me and the session went really well.
Related to computer science, I want to remind you all that in March,
for the first time, the department will, not for the first time, but the department will bring to you for action the California Computer Science Strategic Implementation Plan they shared with you at the last board meeting.
This will be the first time for action.
And just a little bit of a heads up that because of some last minute changes to the statute that created this process, there are some glitches in it.
that wouldn't have been there, that weren't there before.
So it's not typical for us to adopt necessarily strategic plans that are, you know, strategic plans.
And the way it's written is that the board has until July 15th to get the strategic plan over to the legislature.
Adopted.
If adopted,
the strategic plan for computer science must go to the legislature before July 15th.
Did I say July?
Okay.
And so that's just something to be aware of.
You may not like that plan in March.
There may be things in it you feel uncomfortable with because if you adopted it, basically it's saying you endorse the approach.
And so you'll have March, May, and the early meeting in July to get it into a kind of a shape that you're comfortable with.
The other glitch in the statute 2329 is that the plan is actually considered separate from the recommendations of the advisory panel.
So the recommendations of that blue ribbon governor's state board superintendent advisory panel will be going over to the legislature in January.
Just the recommendations not as part of a plan.
Yes.
I had a question about the plan.
Is this considered an instructional or learning plan for schools to implement or is this considered a policy for the state about computer science?
It's a lot like think of the NGSS state implementation plan.
It has to do with how are we going to recruit.
The two main areas of emphasis in the statute is
How do we generate a large enough pool of teachers in order to be able to have equitable access for students in computer science?
And then how do we ensure equitable access?
So it's a state level thing, not an instructional thing.
All right.
The reason I was asking so that you know what my motives or my concern was for asking is I was wondering, not knowing clearly what the whole content was, if there was a role for the IQC in vetting or advising the board on the plan itself.
It is with the IQC.
Okay.
It's been out for public comment the last 30 days that just ended this week.
The strategic plan came to the IQC?
Uh-huh.
I must have missed that meeting.
Yes.
Yeah.
And that's the only 30.
They did a 30 day public comment.
And it's the only one they're doing.
And the IQC will be looking at it in January.
Yeah.
And then they might have to look at it again and again, depending on how you guys feel about it.
OK.
So I just wanted to bring that up because I won't be here in March.
And so I don't know who on the board is going to be able to talk to you about it.
Another thing is, it's my understanding, I'm waiting for an update, but it's my understanding that the UC systems, speaking of tectonic plates moving, it's my understanding that the UC BORS still is moving forward with a decision to include, to allow computer science as well as environmental science and several other engineering, computer engineering to count under Area D.
They did an announcement.
They posted an announcement saying it.
What they haven't done yet, that I can tell, is make edits to the description of Area D under the goals and course criteria that would allow for virtual labs, virtual experiments to meet the lab requirement.
And so the last I heard from Monica Lynn at UC Boards,
is that the plan was to have that work done and then begin announcing to districts, to schools, that these changes are made.
There have been edits to Area D that allow for virtual.
Otherwise, everything else in Area D remains the same.
They have to meet that in order to qualify under D. And that it would be for submissions of courses that would go into effect in the 2019-20 year.
Okay, I want to say also on ACCS, as you know, Member Holiday and I virtually attended that meeting and when Sue, Member Burr, said that we are recruiting
to replace Brian Bauer.
There is no replacement for Brian Bauer.
We are recruiting to replace a charter opening representation, and Brian has been the chair for 10 years, and I do not think I could have stayed in this role for the past eight if he had not been the chair.
Of course, this guy made all the difference in the world, too, because we've teamed and partnered so well on this.
But Brian has also been just such steady, calm, smart leadership, and that he would give up his time to do this when he's running a huge charter school down in L.A.
and doing all kinds.
In fact, that charter school,
just got approved for expansion.
It's the largest charter high school in the United States, and now they're building an elementary and middle school to create a feeder pattern.
So he's a very busy guy, and we've been very lucky to have him this long.
A couple other things.
Probably the most important thing is in the October 13th, my son Elliot got married to Caroline Rubin, and it was an absolutely wonderful wedding.
We love this young woman.
I feel so fortunate that she and I just bonded so quickly and get along so well, and this is just like a hugely
happy, happy moment for me.
So if you haven't seen some of the wedding pictures, you'll see them at the next meeting.
Okay, that's when we get the professional pictures.
And then last thing is you're talking a little bit about how things are changing and looking forward.
And so like with CSU reconsidering some of the requirements, that kind of thing.
One of the things I've gotten interested in, in part because I now, you know, am in the kind of the technology computer science space,
But also just in general, as I think about leaving the board and I'm looking forward, is I've been, I've got a folder here that I brought with me called the future of education.
And one of the things I've been noticing is articles like from the World Economic Forum, what kind of education do we need in the future?
I ordered a book that just came out from the OECD, the Organization for Economic Cooperation and Development.
They've got a book that's called Future School, Future Education Next, something like that.
That's a pretty thick book.
World class, world class education, what should it have in it?
And then part of this is motivated by this article
In the LA Times, millions of Californians' jobs could be affected by automation, a scenario the next governor has to address.
So, when I heard the international organization, whose name I can't remember, release that report about how fast climate change is going to evolve in the next decade and a half, and how fast automation is going to evolve in the next decade and a half,
It's caused me to be really interested in making sure I know something about that and thinking through what we talk.
We tend to talk in ways that have to do with how we are now.
Instead of algebra, let's have statistics.
Instead of just lab science, let's also allow computer science.
But those are good changes, but they're small changes compared to the rest of some of the bigger, bigger geopolitical and climate changes that are going to be facing us.
And I don't know how, how we're going to grapple with those kinds of things and figure that out fast enough.
So on that upbeat note.
Okay, thank you.
We're down now.
We're going to have Tom talk a little bit at the end.
Item 21, public comment for items not on our agenda.
Is there any public comment?
Actually, we have one public comment for number 20 Angela de Ramos Okay, but you have the public comment.
Oh, yeah Okay, and moving on to 21.
We have Terry Burns Park Guthrie Lola Guthrie Kai Guthrie June Guthrie and Krista Engelhofer
I just wanted to thank you, Mr. Chairman, for your kind remarks yesterday that I was caught off guard.
I was still upstairs, but I enjoyed them very much.
And thank you.
I want to thank all of the board.
It's been a pleasure working with you all this last year.
And I want to tell you what a pleasure it's been working with your incredibly competent and thoughtful staff.
all great people to work with and a real pleasure.
So thank you for the kind words and I look forward to seeing you all in future endeavors.
As we... Thank you very much.
Appreciate it.
My name is Park Guthrie.
I'm a career California public school teacher and parent of three students.
Thank you for your very important work.
Please pass a nonpartisan climate action resolution.
It will help move Congress to act.
In an ideal world, it would not fall to you to speak up for national climate action.
But as a nation, we have not acted responsibly on climate change.
All of us here recognize that this national inaction is a direct threat to all California kids and future generations.
We recognize this especially clearly today, a day in which tens of thousands of students have had school canceled due to climate-related fires.
To date, 27 school boards and one student council have passed climate action resolutions
including four county offices of Ed and the 10th largest district in the nation, Fairfax County.
The Pacific trustees of the National School Boards Association have submitted a strong climate action resolution that will be considered next spring.
Your example of speaking up for national climate action to protect students would cost nothing, but would set an inspirational example for school boards, student councils, and students across the nation, and it would help move Congress to act.
Thank you very much.
Hi, my name is Kristen Klingelhofer.
As a mother and a public school educator, I value everything you do to create our great schools in California.
Thank you.
Our schools serve and protect our children.
As an educator, I'm a mandated reporter bound by law to speak out when I suspect neglect or abuse.
Our national silence and inaction on climate change is generational neglect.
Our children are in harm's way, and we are all witnesses to it.
It's heartbreaking to know that great harm will come to our kids and that we as a nation are not doing everything in our power.
that we are largely silent on this real and growing threat.
As educators, our entire focus is on the future and well-being of students.
We can and must all speak out in a nonpartisan way and call on Congress to protect our children and future generations.
Please pass a climate action resolution.
It's a small action that would send a big signal and could make a powerful impact on all the children who you serve so well.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is June Guthrie.
I'm a sixth grader at a public school.
Today, I woke up and I realized that school was canceled because of climate change related fire.
And no need to worry about my test on Ancient Realm.
I knew that there is something much more than aqueducts and routes.
Climate change is a threat to my future.
Please speak up for my generation and me.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Kai Guthrie.
I'm a sophomore at Credo High School in Roanoke Park and I'm one of the co-founders of the Schools for Climate Action campaign.
Thank you for all the work you do on behalf of students across the state.
We as a nation can solve climate change.
We have the technology and we have the economy necessary to tackle this problem.
All that we lack is public and political will.
My school's student council passed a resolution calling on Congress to act.
It also specifically asked your board to pass a similar resolution.
Unfortunately, some of the educational leaders have been silent about climate justice as an issue.
I was told by a longtime staffer at the California School Boards Association that climate change as a justice issue and a children's issue was too politically charged for their organization to monitor.
I ask that you will speak up for this issue, for all the students that you work so hard for every day.
Your voice on this issue could have a big impact and help move Congress.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, trustees.
My name is Lola Guthrie.
I'm a ninth grader and a co-founder of Schools for Climate Action.
Thank you for the important work that you do for children.
I am here because the threat that climate change poses on my generation is too great to ignore, and yet the educational sector, whose sole focus is on the success of youth, has barely spoken up for climate justice.
I believe that climate change is a generational justice and human rights issue because the youth who will bear the greatest burden of climate change are least responsible for its cause.
This is generational neglect, and it's not just an idea.
I tasted the neglect in the back of my throat when I stepped outside of school yesterday into a smoky haze.
I saw the neglect when the seemingly endless stream of hurricanes demolished coastal communities.
I heard the neglect when my middle school superintendent said that it was too political to address climate change.
But then the board did, and so can you.
Please speak up to bring justice to this situation.
Thank you.
Thank you for that.
And now, Tom, you're going to make some closing comments.
Yes, thank you.
And what an articulate group of students and family.
Thank you.
And as you heard the dialogue, and I'm always impressed with the reports, the work you're doing, each of you as board members out there really making a difference.
And you might have heard from that dialogue, there's quite a concern among our board members about climate change.
Taking action and and we are and we have the environmental literacy plan and Bruce and others have been working the science efforts All to the positive, but I mainly wanted to say say this.
It's a last meeting for someone of quiet strength who's a leader and
behind whom you've seen, you mentioned all the reports we get, all the outstanding staff work we get.
I'm speaking of Glenn Price.
And I just wanted to say something about Glenn, that he is a quiet, he leads with quiet strength.
He knows how to build teams.
He knows talent and commitment.
He knows how to retrain, you know, recruit and train and build that team spirit that's been so effective.
So behind all this action is someone I have put down super.
Super leader, super creative leader, super mentor, super listener, super capacity builder,
It goes on and on, because he's that kind of leader and strategist, creative.
And I could not have accomplished what I have been able to get done without Glenn.
So I say that with big thanks and wishing him the best for the future.
Could Glenn, you just stand up and let's just recognize.
Okay.
Thank you.
And I just had one last thing.
And it just shows, it'll show how crisis can lead to positive moving forward.
But Glenn and our office have been involved in the OES the last three years.
Increasingly, unfortunately, because of the fires, many of which are stemming from global climate changes.
But basically, I just wanted to give a quick report.
Today, we had over 200,000 students out of school.
Just one community alone, Sonoma, had a number of schools closed, 130 schools closed, 54 students out.
The town of Paradise in Butte County, 27,000 people, 80% of the town is gone.
There are 3,000 to 3,500 students who have no home tonight.
Their homes are gone.
Over 2,000 structures have been damaged in the process.
So our office works with the OES in terms of school recovery, school reopening.
But I just wanted to mention that so that we can keep the victims of these tragedies in our minds.
In our prayers as we move forward and One of the things I've noticed is that in the midst of this kind of crisis that we see the best side of human nature where people come to help neighbor helping neighbor taking risks to help others and You know doing it in a noble way.
So I just wanted to say let's keep them in our mind and in our prayers.
Thank you.
Thank you Board is adjourned